e
e e
order and ask everyone to please uh
follow me in the pledge of
allegiance to the flag of the United
States of America and to the
rep God
indivisible andice for
all thank
you now open the hearing on House Bill
and recognize the prime sponsor
representative Mark
Pearson good morning Mr chairman and
members of the committee for the record
my name is Mark Pearson this is my ninth
year in the house on Tuesdays I sit
where you sit as chairman of Children
and Family Law committee
I am in my third 2-year term chairing
the DHHS oversight committee I have a
master's degree from Oxford
representative McFarland and a doctorate
from Boston
University when I was growing up as a
blue collar kid in a mtown west of
Boston in the
1950s most of the adults in my town were
conservative
Democrats sometimes called lunch bucket
liberals we did have some Republicans
divided between old Yankee farmers and
shopkeepers and Country Club Republicans
Titans of
Industry once in a while though the
goooo that's what they were called The
Good Government Democrats spoke to us
from their Loft in Cambridge and
sometimes they said something that made
sense I remember one of the things that
they stressed and we all
accepted freedom of
conscience these good government
Cambridge liberals spoke of the crushed
attempt in Hungary to break free of
communist oppression they referenced how
in the 1930s in Germany and continuing
on since 1918 and what was once Russia
there was no freedom of conscience if
you had talent and ability you did what
what you were told no matter what your
personal belief system
was or
else later on folks in my town were
supporters of the Vietnam War but we did
understand there was a place for
conscientious
objectors reluctantly we concluded that
sometimes the Goos made
sense I'm part-time CEO of a medical
clinic my wife is a practicing
physician we see the great need for
protection of ethical medicine and the
conscience of Health Care Professionals
and students alike if we start to move
against
conscience where will it end the present
environment where students and those
already in practice a toll to ignore
their convictions in making ethical
decisions has led to
increasing moral injury is the term
amongst
professionals students in fear of
speaking up in their academic
institutions you can speak all the truth
you want to power but good luck in your
career the reluctance of speaking truth
to power a hesitation to pursue certain
Specialties for fear of the pressure to
violate one's conscience and the erosion
of thinking and acting ethically in
general my wife is a senior mentor to a
number of medical students in Northern
New England and what I speak of I have
heard personally from numbers of those
students we know of people who have been
forced
out my wife's written testimony which is
attached to my testimony gives an
example names dates facts places you can
look it up we know of Physicians who are
actively looking to leave New Hampshire
for states where their conscience will
be honored on certain matters we know of
others who will not come
here and believe me since the medical
facility she is C oo of and I am
chairman of the board of our recruiting
and we are hearing from people who even
though we will not force them to violate
conscience wonder that if they move to
New Hampshire and seek another job
eventually they might have a
problem this bill is intended to protect
diversity of belief within the medical
profession and will benefit patients by
protecting the supply of ethical Health
Care
Professionals this bill does not permit
a refusal to serve a person on the basis
of their race color sex or any other
protected characteristic it simply
protects them from being forced to
perform specific procedures this bill is
specifically limited to conscience-based
objections to very specific procedures
and does not allow for a general
discrimination against any
patient such medical persons cannot
refuse to care for an
individual I ran this bill
by your chairman Bob Lynn and he said
well there were a few things in it or
few things not in it that caused him
some
problems and I said what are
those there are two and that is the
amendment that I put in yesterday after
I talked with
him number one what if a person
decides to take a job offer from an
organization that is mostly about
abortions and sterilizations and so on
and then gets into that facility and
decides to invoke an ethical objection
well first of all I really don't expect
that to happen but it might somebody
might do it to weaponize medicine to
deliberately take that job be hired
refuse to do it get fired and
Sue the amendment does not protect a
person who acts that way plus and I was
talking with one of your members uh
beforehand what if you're in a little
country facility way up where on the
weekend you're kind of it and somebody
comes in and needs a
procedure in an emergency to save that
person's life this bills carves that out
the amendment carves that out as well I
appreciate chairman Lynn's
clarifications because I want this to be
fair straight across the board a primary
motivation for this bill is to ensure
that Health Care Professionals come to
and stay in New Hampshire to serve our
residents and are not forced to leave
which will hurt the supply of care here
by protecting rights of conscience we
are protecting the quality of care
available abortion is not going away
here anytime soon so this bill will help
protect some of our best Health Care
Professionals who would otherwise leave
to practice in States more hospitable if
they came in the first place let me
conclude by saying I am arguing this
from the left politically I'm arguing
this from the good government liberals
of Cambridge Massachusetts who taught me
and people in my blue collar miltown
something about
tolerance something about the right of
conscience I'm arguing it from that
direction it is not primarily about
abortion although obviously it's
mentioned it is about conscience it is
about
liberality so that's that's what I have
to offer Mr chairman thank you any
questions of this
witness copies of um the amendment the
amendment the amendment and of the
testimony because um the sponsor
referred to the testimony he did
indicate he was going to turn testimony
in I
I do you have a copy of the amendment as
well there it
is if anyone else has a uh P card you
can turn that in over here
representative
Horgan I'm wondering
um you you picked out a fairly narrow
range of medical procedures where you
can exercise your right of conscience so
why is it just those particular
procedures and not uh a wider range of
procedures because there probably are
other procedures that at least some
individuals may have ethical qualms
about participating in thank you
representative for your question that's
a very good question I've been thinking
about that um these are the people with
whom my wife and I have been speaking
this is their particular issue there may
well be other issues too as you state
and let somebody else come with a bill
on that issue or those
issues this is the issue that uh we are
responding to in part because of a
couple of experiences of people being
fired in this state so that's why we're
not saying it's the only one we're just
saying that's the one we have chosen to
work with at this
time thank you representative
penel thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative Pearson for taking my
question we have all seen the headlines
coming out of states such as Texas where
they have heartbeat laws and the claims
that Physicians are unable to
treat persons who have participated in
an abortion who come into a hospital
facility and um have been purported to
be denied treatment now I personally
find it unconscionable that a physician
would deny treatment to a woman who
is the subject of a medical emergency
because she did something thing that the
physician didn't agree with I believe it
is the duty of the physician to care for
somebody
regardless of how they got themselves
into that pos position or whether it was
from somebody else is there anything in
this bill that would
prevent um a physician from treating
somebody or would it be unconscionable
for a physician to treat somebody in the
state of New Hampshire should they come
in to the hospital
suffering from the result of an abortion
that has not gone the best
way if I understand your question the
abortion has already taken
place yes this does not deal with that
this is conscience about being asked to
perform an abortion and the carve outs
or the Amendments is saying that is not
an
emergency if it's not an emergency and
you the doctor do not wish to perform
one this protects you it also carves out
if you're the only doctor in a little
facility and the person's coming in in
extremist you're going to go
ahead that's what this does thank you
very much you're welcome representative
MOS thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question I'm reading your
Amendment and it says um nor shall the
section apply to a healthcare provider
who is the only health care provider
present in an emergency situation and I
want to ask you who determines whether
it's an emergency situation is it the
health care provider who would as a
matter of conscience um choose not to
participate is it the
institution is it the treat who is it
and do we end up in a case where the
Ethics Committee of the health facility
has to determine or
litigate um whether it's an emergency
situation prior to care being provided
to the person and I'm extremely
concerned about that well you who
determines normally if this is an
emergency go to an ER and you will see
that there are people who jump ahead of
30 other people sitting there in the
room why because it has been determined
and it's whoever the triage or triage
person is it's obvious this person is in
extremist and the other ones are going
to have to wait their turn this happens
all the time in Ys and that's what we
would have here a person comes in not
saying I've decided I want to have an
abortion this person is coming in where
it is pretty obvious the life of the
mother is being threatened there's
various actions and noises and things
that go on with being in extremist it
should be pretty obvious and it would
not necessarily be that doctor there are
other people in the ER nurses and other
people there and it would look pretty
obvious now I would imagine that if
the physician says oh no everything's
well first of all I would not imagine
that happening but let's say it did that
person would be subject to sanctions for
refusing emergency care to somebody
who's having
emergency representative Perez thank you
having worked in emergency rooms in
intensive care and 15 bed hospitals in
the mountain um are you aware that
emergencies are determined by a person's
vital signs not just what they say so
emergency can be
determined simply by the fact that there
are certain things that occur they're
bleeding their blood pressure is
dropping their heart rate's going up um
their pain level is a
10 uh yes I would I'm the um unruly one
in the family I'm the liberal arts guy
much of my family are doctors nurses
nursing professors and so on and
occasionally I listen to them and yeah
that's what they told me
too representative tur yeah thank you
and thanks for taking the question um I
will say I have a a range of concerns on
on this um and I shared the ones that
you raised for um uh that that chairman
Lynn raised um I'm going to add one that
I think uh as I read the bill there's
two things one is it seems that this is
worded to apply not just to Providers of
medical care but to basically any staff
that would be at the facilities in
question um and my my concern really is
not that part as much as when it's says
that you can consciously conscientiously
object there's no process laid out here
for what that means it the way it I read
this it is largely a mental decision
that you made and then you took action
based on that mental decision so as as
the administrator of a of a medical
facility would it would it give you any
concern that your say scheduler might
have somebody calling asking for a
procedure and that person would
basically make a mental decision saying
I'm consciously objecting turn them away
and you you might not even know this was
happening there's no process that I can
see laid out for what
objecting in involves in order that that
this be in the light of day does that
question make sense yes it
does that wasn't the
question I think you're asking the chair
for a
followup I I guess I need to M Mr chair
follow up reiterating what I originally
said does it give you any concern or do
you see a problem with the idea that
that objecting in this bill is a process
that could take place solely in
someone's mind and that they could take
action that nobody would even be aware
that they
took I'm trying to run this as a
parallel to conscientious objection to
the Vietnam War but I'm not having great
success doing that but I'll work on that
uh
yeah I I don't P believe
that a switchboard person would say oh
sorry I don't like what you're asking so
I'm not going to schedule it I think
anybody who did that would be fired on
any grounds I do hang out enough in our
business office to overhear what our
switchboard people say
and if it's uh what the patient wants
and it's within our scope of service as
a family practice office they will
simply put in the schedule I I've never
heard anybody say uh we don't do it
because I don't believe it we don't do
major surgery because we're not surgeons
so they would say I'm sorry I cannot
take out your gallbladder is not an
ethical question it's simply we're not
qualified to do that so one can I have
one more followup please quickly so I I
just wanted to draw your attention um to
uh page two lines uh you know 17 18 19
where it defines what participate or
participating in means um and it seems
to include things like referring for and
then later on in that in on line 18
admit for the purposes of providing so
it seems to
Encompass um any hospital or clinic
employee from line 14 so that that's
just to clarify why uh I think that
that's an issue all right let me respond
to that by saying if a facility has that
as its policy it is quote pro-life
facility I think that would fit if you
are saying that there might be a one
physician on the staff that has this
conscience uh and the switchboard person
intaking has that and makes the decision
on his or her own even though other
people in the facility would be willing
to do that yeah I think you've got a
point there I mean I think that could be
tweaked
yeah thank you any other questions
representative McFarland thank you
chairman my first question I I was
appreciative of Representative Horgan's
question because I was going to ask you
the same thing but I think seeing as
you've answered that I I think the thing
that I'm struggling with with that
answer is that you are indicating you
have had experience is with people who
have been threatened with or or have
lost their jobs because of these kind of
uh conscientious concerns and to my
understanding not that I uh would object
to having similar language in State
Statute there is language in the federal
statutes that's commonly referred to as
the Wen Amendment are you familiar with
that vaguely I'd be happy to know more
about that if you could shoot that to me
at some point fair enough I mean my
question was essentially going to be if
you knew why that had not been able to
protect these individuals but uh uh
given that you you don't have that
context I I will leave that one may I
have a follow-up question followup um so
with regard to your
Amendment would you be amenable to
changing the first sentence of that
amendment to read this section shall not
apply to a health care provider employed
by a health care institution into a role
where such Healthcare institution
expects that individual provider to
provide abortion St Iz ation artificial
contraception as a major part of his
services and the reason for my question
is it troubles me that the way it's
written at the moment in that amendment
I don't know how to interpret or how the
courts would interpret a major part of
uh a large organization such as as you
know our Hospital organization
Services I think this was dashed off by
ol very quickly at the end of yesterday
morning I having dashed it off quickly
just before before that having talked to
Chairman Lyn I I think what this was
is a facility that makes this a major
part of what they do and then you decide
to go to work there really you know
you're either disingenuous by half or
you really haven't thought it through um
I I want to use a different example
and it may be a stretch and it has
nothing to do with
Healthcare the baseballer Sandy kofax
Jewish would not pitch on the Sabbath
for the Los Angeles Dodgers he was still
on the team and they worked around him
in my hometown we had a couple of Jewish
firefighters who no matter when their
schedule call for them to work they
would work on Christmas so the
Christians could have the day off and in
turn Christians would work on the day of
atonement so a Jewish firefighter could
have the day off these were
workarounds so in a facility where there
are numbers of
people it could be people of Good Will
honoring conscience of teamw workers
could make allowances for that person
who is saying I have ethical objections
because other people there could do
those things I think this is honest and
decent and in keeping with good
Cambridge 1960 liberalism and if I may
chairman I mean I I I hope you are right
do you think it's likely that a hospital
organization uh in the state if this
were passed and with this amendment do
you think it's likely that they would
try and claim that a major part of their
services as the entity as a whole and
I'm not talking about a particular
clinic or a particular facility I'm
talking about the hospital organization
as a whole performs these Services as a
major part of their services I think
it's pretty obvious to prove one way or
the other what percentage what
procedures do you do here in your ER and
in your surgical Suites and so on what
percentage of that is an abortion I
think it's pretty obvious to say either
this is a facility that majors in this
or it
isn't representative pel Mr chair I have
a procedural question um is it or is it
not appropriate for a member of our
committee to speak without being
recognized by the chair it is not
appropriate thank you thank you any
other questions of this Witness
representative
rbo thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question um to piggy back on
representative tur's question as I read
this a re a receptionist or
Administrative Assistant could decline
to schedule uh a potential patient would
not need to inform anyone at the
employer would not need to inform the
person who's seeking the appointment um
would not need to refer them anywhere
else um is that
that's my first question to correct is
that correct that is not the
intent and but is that the is that the
way the bill is written is that if I
believe some people could infer that and
good language will take away the
possibility of multiple inferences from
a single sentence and it could well be
that a redo of this amendment would take
that into
account okay may one follow up one
follow up thank you and and would you
agree that this is different from a
conscientious objection for instance on
the Vietnam War where you were
mentioning where there was a process
where you would need to fill out a form
go before a board discuss um there was
an approval process uh and and how does
that inform your thoughts on employer
rights here if they are a facility that
provides these services and they don't
have any ability to have Insight you
know to be informed if somebody is
declining to provide scheduling for
services I would expect in the interview
process when Dr Smith um applies for uh
a position that's being advertised this
would come up I think it would be
improper for Dr Smith to take the job
and then suddenly say oh by the way now
that I'm here now that there's a
contract by the way I can't do this this
this uh I would think that in the
interview process this would be made
clear and if the hospital wishes to go
ahead and hire that person there would
be an understanding that this um uh
invocation of conscience has been
accepted by the facility if they didn't
want to take that person onto the staff
they would simply say
so thank you representative tur thank
you Mr chair and uh thanks again for
taking another question um I I don't
want to
lose uh sight of a significant portion
of what's in this bill which is not
related to abortion but is related to
provision of contraception um and as I
read it it's basically all forms of
contraception
um I see on page two line five that
things like pharmacies are considered
under the definition of a health care
institution you know so I think this
gets at both the bill and the proposed
amendment you know what's a significant
portion of your business you know I
would say that most this is a question I
assume yes yes sorry I would I would say
that I would say that most of what a
pharmacy does is not the provision of
contraception but they are the major
providers of contraception so I
guess similar to what we asked earlier
would it be the person at the checkout
counter would it be the person any staff
person within a pharmacy who could
invoke this provision and say we're not
going to offer um or assist or or even
check you out for a contraceptive
device I think that's a fair
question and this is what I love to do
in my committee is rewrite the bill in
real time and so thank you for the
various inputs I hope this won't be
exact for a while um I don't know if
it's an early bill or not I should know
that but I don't
um but in any case uh I've heard some
good things here which do not go to the
heart of what I want but seem to uh add
on to what chairman Lynn raised as
concerns I don't expect this to uh go on
a consent calendar but I would like to
make it what I had hoped it would be and
remove as many uh let's back up and take
into
account numbers of good points that have
been made today which to me
not kill the bill but it makes it
perhaps more widely palatable thank you
any other questions of this witness
seeing none thank you thank
you representative Paige
boerman thank you Mr chair and thank you
committee for hearing me today nice to
be in front of you again um my name is
Paige boschman I represent NASA's Ward 4
as I have said to the committee before I
am a women's Maternal Child health nurse
I have served in high-risk prenatal care
I have done inhospital labor and
delivery as a labor and delivery nurse I
have worked in a birth center and I've
worked with uh women and families
prenatally and postnatally as well as
doing gynecological care and prenatal
office work I say all of that to give
you some examples of uh where my
experience lies now I I do want to bring
up a few points I just have a I have a
lot of questions about this bill which
is what I would like to bring up today
first of all I would like to say that we
heard uh previously that nobody would do
that uh my question about that is well
then why do we need the bill it clearly
happens because the whole point of this
bill came from providers who were fired
for doing just that so I would argue
that it does happen um I have a few
questions as I said um my biggest
question here is exactly what repur said
which is that we might talk about
abortion but when we bring in the
subject of contraception I fear for the
health and well-being of many of the
women in our state first of all I would
like to give a few examples so uh about
12 years ago I would take calls from
women in the middle of having
miscarriages they would pre be
prescribed a medical uh pill that would
help them to release the products of
conception as we call it I cannot tell
you how many times even back then I
would call in the prescription to a
pharmacy and be questioned by the
pharmacist about why they that was being
prescribed so I do see this as a problem
and I see it happening I'd like to have
another uh example of contraception
which is having the a uh layman's terms
having your tubes tied um I have been
witnessed to a situation where a woman
came in for labor she then ended up
having a c-section she had already made
the decision that at some point after
this baby she wanted her tubes tied now
because she was having a c-section that
was the perfect time she could had that
done and had one operation because she
was in a facility where they did not do
that which was her choice at that time I
see that but because of that she had to
recover from her C-section be closed up
recover from her C-section then go back
at another time with a new baby have the
risks of anesthesia infection and
getting another procedure I don't think
that that's something that people should
be subjected to without knowing that
that could be something that happens I
think about our small rural towns in New
Hampshire where if that is the only
obstetrician on that night is that what
might happen to that person are they
going to close somebody up and then have
them come back to have another surgery
I'd also like to question um when we
talk about who Health Care Providers are
there's actually a line that says any
other person who furnishes artificial
contraception does that mean the clerk
at the only Pharmacy or the only drug
store in town or the only Little Town
store uh who doesn't want to sell
condoms are we impeding or increasing
the re the risk of STI and STDs I would
like to call attention also to the point
that there's nothing in here that says
that a person has to divulge this ahead
of time and I think that's a real
problem I would argue that contraception
is one of the main services that
Obstetricians and gynecologists engage
in and therefore my opinion as I see it
would be that every obstetric off office
unless they unless they explicitly say
that's not what they do one of their
main roles is to provide contraception
not just for birth control but for a
number a number of other health care
conditions or other conditions that
women may experience I think this is a
very dangerous bill I think there's a
lot uh that we're not looking at here I
do believe that although we think that
legally if if it needs to be done for
life-saving measures what we've seen in
other states you can look up Texas and
all the women that have died there since
their abortion band when things are not
explicitly clear providers are not clear
and Confused um we know that in Texas a
woman had awful Vital Signs they knew
that she was dying of sepsis they did
not interfere until her vitals got to
such a low level that they could not
save her we know that this is not being
interpreted correctly and it's a very
slippery slope I can go on but I'll
leave it there and I hope I do get some
good
questions question this witness
representative
Horgan um thank you very much there is a
definition artificial conception in the
in the bill which it doesn't really
doesn't specifically mention condoms but
it I mean I think probably it's
intended to like restrict procedures
that are performed on women rather than
men but um so
so so so do you so would you agree that
uh the condom might be covered under uh
under those uh the defin is artificial
contraception or contraception in the
bill yeah a condom is artificial
contraception so I would imagine it
could be argued that is how I
interpreted
it thank you representative Bergeron
thank you chair and thank you in advance
for answering my question I wanted to
just ask you given the
exposure you've had to several different
environments what was your first
reaction when you read about the eight
and a half by
11 that has to be posted and the reason
I'm asking is I'm not sure you know do
people like look at that and decide not
to stay because they're in that
emergency department or whatnot do they
see that paper and then go and then but
I'm just kind of curious what your
reaction was to that my reaction is if
the bill passed I do think it's
important for us to know our rights so
if that is something that passed I think
that anything that is in statute that we
have as a right should be posted but as
I said before I I believe that that
could lead to people who did not divulge
it or who didn't know they get a job
they find out and then I do believe
especially in places where we are we are
so under staffed in maternal healthc
care providers in this state and if we
allow people to go into practices and
then divulge this we are putting some of
these small practices at a huge
disadvantage and a huge cost for them
trying to shuffle things around this is
different than observing a day where you
can plan ahead and you know what day you
can switch with the firefighters Etc
this is in the moment care that comes up
you can't take the time to shuffle
things around potentially in an
emergency
situation so I I do not think from that
perspective that that would be something
that would be
beneficial representative McFarland
thank you Mr chairman bearing in mind
that the language of the bill speaks to
notices requiring to be posted and I
quote in a location in which healthc
care providers are likely to see such a
notice is it your professional
experience that such notices to the
healthc care employees and providers
would be posted in the public waiting
room or in a room that they are are in
uh as providers in my experience we only
post things in my experience I've only
seen notices posted in a waiting area if
it pertains to Patient rights my
experience is that this kind of thing is
you know usually around a Time clock or
somewhere in the back wherever the
employee room is thank you that's where
our rights are posted thank you thank
you representative panel thank you for a
second I'd like to kind of turn this
around um I have heard of patients
seeking treatment in particular for
fertility concerns only to find out that
the very physician who is attempting to
assist them with their fertility issues
is also performing abortions and they
had were not informed formed of that and
so they found out that they were
receiving care from a physician who was
doing things that were against their
good
conscience would it be um maybe not in
this bill but would you suggest that
maybe it should be posted in medical
facilities that abortions are performed
in this facility if that is something
that you don't want to be morally
participating in in any way I'm I'm all
thank you for that question I'm always
in favor of informing patients and and
having them know as much as possible and
I I'm not frankly
opposed to people who want to do this in
a facility where that's happening and
where it's well known I do think it
would be very difficult in a
facility to H to be there and know that
some people do this and some people
don't that's much harder to
identify
um it's it's also I'm so sorry I lost my
train of thought for just a second
um it's also something that right now is
the responsibility of a patient right if
I become pregnant and I want to know how
much I don't know how many C-sections
this obstetrician does I ask them what
is your C-section rate what are your
Specialties right you can look that up
so I do believe that while I support
that I think that right now when we're
looking at other topics that is
something that is on the patient to
determine
follow up is it possible and know we're
getting a little way away from the bill
but that a patient might not be
aware that there are procedures or
situations being performed in a hospital
until they are actually offered those
Services
themselves you know I don't know that I
can speak to that specifically I'm not
every patient um not not to be flippant
but um I I
do I think that most people know that
most gynecologist and Obstetricians
engage in health care and and abortion
is a part of Health Care as is
contraception and I don't want to forget
that contraception is a big part of this
spill I think it's pretty well known if
if you want to get contraception you're
going to an obstetrician so I I do think
that that is something that most people
should be aware of and that their
concerns are likely the exception and
they have every right to ask about that
thank you you any of the questions
representative Perez thank you thanks
for taking my question I worked in three
Catholic Hospitals in my medical career
I did intensive care ER recovery room
over 42 years each Catholic Hospital
that I went to work at I had to sign a
their policy and their um I forget all
different things
that say that what they do and do not do
in that and I had to sign that I agreed
with
them are you telling me that that isn't
the real world anymore actually yes I
just recently left St Joe's Hospital in
nsha which is a Catholic Hospital and
that was my question during the
interview obviously you can understand
where I'm coming from in healthcare and
I wanted to ensure that I wouldn't be in
any kind of uh you know a violation of a
policy if I spoke about those things and
educated my patients as I should and
they assured me that it was absolutely
not anything that was against what the
hospital stood for and I would I'm just
telling you my experience in the last
year at at a hospital that is a Catholic
Hospital and again people going there
know what they're going to because it's
a Catholic Hospital thank you
representative
mayos thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question I wanted to get
back to um contra reception and I wanted
to ask is one of the uses of condoms to
prevent the transmission of
HIV and if so by enabling a pharmacist
to deny the provision of uh condoms are
you in fact increasing the risk to the
patient of the transmission of HIV thank
you thank you for that question and I
would like to clarify my um
interpretation of this would mean
Pharmacy and store clerk uh so I do or
even you know I work in a sexual
Wellness Clinic where we test for STI
and
STDs and we give out condoms so what if
somebody there doesn't want to give
condoms right that that's not that is
not best practice of course and so the
answer to your question is absolutely it
opens the door as we're in right now
could be interpreted to not sell condoms
and that will absolutely increase the
risk of STI
HIV thank you any other questions of
this
witness representative rmo yeah I just
wanted to just again to return to the
language of the bill and would you agree
that the way this is written
receptionist could turn away a patient
for any other provider in the uh
facility knew the patient needed care
I'm sorry I couldn't can you speak up
sply and too far away um would you agree
the way this bill is written a
receptionist could turn away a patient
without anyone else at the facility
knowing that that individual needed care
I read this carefully and yes I do
interpret that I do believe that could
be interpreted in that way okay there is
there is nothing that says that um that
requires that a person would inform
anybody else that they've taken that
action thank you thank you any other
questions seeing none thank you thank
you very much for your time
everybody Rebecca Hodgkins
hello my name is Rebecca Hoskins and I
was born and raised here in New
Hampshire born in New London raised in
Dairy went to Plymouth State University
and currently reside here in conquer
I've come to speak to you today to tell
you my story and urgently oppose hb23 to
this bill would result in people across
our state being denied access to
Essential Medical Care and in some cases
dying as a
result my first period landed me in the
hospital I woke up that morning in pain
like I had never felt before and my legs
were just covered in blood I somehow
managed to drag myself to the bathroom
before the vomiting began and that's
where my parents found me and rushed me
to the ER from there I received
emergency care and a referral to an
OBGYN that first period was 10 days of
heavy bleeding it was immediately clear
that something was wrong the OBG ran
agreed and even said it seemed very
likely that I had endometriosis and
should be put on birth control right
away to try to control the bleeding pain
and other symptoms over the next several
years I tried almost every birth control
on the market trying to find one that
helped the symptoms without too many
side effects I also received surgery
both to diagnose the endometriosis since
unfortunately it can be it can't be
diagnosed with tests and to have the
standard oblation surgery even so after
this surgery it grew back with a
vengeance as it turned out I actually
had stage four of all three types of
endometriosis in 2018 it had grown back
to the point that it was on most of my
internal organs and was actively
dissolving my appendix inside my body I
needed life-saving surgery which I
thankfully received fast forward to 2024
and the pain was returning again at this
point my doctor and I decided a
hysterectomy would be the best course of
action I received that in August shortly
after my 30th birthday it has been
lifechanging and has allowed me to focus
on other aspects of my health that have
fallen through the cracks if HB 232 had
been law at any point in my journey I
could have been denied birth control
surgery or even life-saving emergency
care and I would have died doctors take
an oath to do no harm it's not a career
where they can pick and choose who
receives care my having endometriosis is
beyond my control and needing birth
control and a hysterectomy in order to
both stay alive and have any hope of a
good quality of life shouldn't be denied
me because it goes against a potential
doctor's beliefs we've seen the real
world harm of bills like this in other
states broad conscious closets have
resulted in denied emergency care for
miscarriages refusals to fill birth
control and even hospitals Turning Away
patients seeking gender affirming care
refusals already happen and this bill
would only expand them with no
accountability
New Hampshire has long stood for
personal freedoms and access to Quality
healthare this bill does the opposite it
prioritizes individual beliefs over
patient safety and allows discrimination
under the guise of conscious for this
reason I urge you to stand with New
Hampshire women birthing people and all
patients who rely on timely essential
Healthcare and vote no on HB 232 thank
you thank you any questions of this
witness representative
McFarland first let me just uh share my
simp for your your circumstances as I'm
sure other members on the committee feel
um you allude to the language of the
bill and I know that you have heard the
testimony from the prime sponsor that he
is not only amenable but he is uh
suggesting that there should be an
amendment that would uh exclude these
emergency
circumstances uh if such an amendment
were to be made to the bill do you feel
the same way
it's again coming back to the who
decides what the emergency is and if
they will choose to follow through if
there is actual need for the emergent
care um I Heard many people talking
about how this seems like it is a
decision that can just be made in a
person's head and that's the main part
that I find concerning I I'm not sure
the amendment would fully cover
that any other questions
seeing none thank
you Kate
Peters hi I'm a family doctor in
Manchester um and I've done a lot of
women's health in the past um throughout
my career I've had the opportunity to
work in uh inpatient settings as a
hospitalist and academic settings and
outpatient settings and a Moonlight in
the jails and I've worked in ers so I
have a a broad perspective about how
healthc care teams work and about the
restrictions that Healthcare teams have
in rural areas and I know a lot of you
are concerned about that too and I guess
I appreciate the clarifying amendments
about emergency situations I think those
are absolutely essential um but I think
that they would need some fine-tuning um
and and my biggest concern is that this
doesn't adequately take into
consideration the restrictions of a
healthcare team in a rural area right
and I think that in general when we look
at our Health Care Systems the the more
restraints we put on those systems the
narrower and narrower access to care
becomes so I have worked in facilities
in other states a small rural Hospital
in California that had a conscious
objection rule like this and staff
members in the operating room were
objecting to certain procedures and so
over time that hospital had to narrow
its ability to provide those procedures
even routine things like Tu liation this
is not a Catholic Hospital um and but
over months and years they had to narrow
and narrow and narrow the opportunities
they had to provide those things saying
we're only going to schedule these on
Thursdays because we know we can staff
so and so who won't object and um and
and then eventually hospitals just
stopped Pro providing those procedures
and so that that's where I see this
leading and that's my concern is that um
you know Healthcare teams are highly
efficient
and and we're trained everyone's trained
to do one very specific thing and
they're not trained to do the other
things right so if some member of your
team objects and they step away it's not
like you know if your operating room
nurse says I'm not going to participate
in this procedure the anesthesiologist
can't go get the blood that the patient
needs and give it to them like that
they're not trained to do that that's
not how the team runs and especially in
rural areas where Staffing is already
very very strained I think if we if we
allow I I guess it's it's putting the
individual's rights over the employer
rights or over the systems rights you
know if we allow people to object then
what I see happening in the future is
that fewer and fewer facilities provide
essential life-saving procedures not
even in only emergency situations but in
non-emergency situations too um so I
think that this unfortunately although
the intentions are good of this bill I
think it will unfortunately have the
side effect of further limiting women's
access to healthcare um which should not
be a goal for any of us thank you
representative pel thank you Mr chair
and thank you for being here and taking
my question in the situation you
described where um fewer and fewer
procedures were being performed is it
possible that the health care providers
were attracted to positions in that
hospital because they could
conscientiously
object although theoretically I can see
how that would be possible the hospital
was never adequately staffed so they
didn't have an overabundance of Staff
they sort of had to work with the staff
that they had and that's why the
procedures became fewer and fewer over
time followup so it sounds more like a
staffing issue than a conscientious
objection issue to me yes but I don't
think they're unrelated right because if
you had if you had adequate staff then
you could have you know people cover
Monday through Friday for all the
procedures you wanted who weren't going
to consciously object but none of our
Healthcare systems work that way all of
them are on skeleton staffs and using
loc's agencies to fill their staffs and
we don't have that opportunity in the
state of New Hampshire right now
especially not in our rural
areas representative
buron thank you Mr chair and thank you
for uh all your
homework I was just curious if you see
this going down and say some of these
emergencies that you've described do
patients have to call around now before
they leave they've got an emergency
going at home or whatnot do they have to
call ahead now to proceed to you know
Healthcare facilities and say do you do
this do you do that do you s my
experience is that patients don't do
that but in some cases they probably
wish they
had yeah I was just curious if you see
that in the direction going down once
you read this yeah no I'm
good representative
McFarland if we believe that there is an
element in what you're relating to us of
of a staffing issue do you consider as
representative pearon alluded to in his
testimony that by not passing this bill
we continue to suffer from uh staffing
issues and uh issues of lack of
diversity because we end up uh pushing
people away who do feel strongly about
these
issues I I can you can you ask that in a
different way I'm not sure I followed
yes I I mean I think we understand that
there are some people who would be
interested in being healthc care
providers in in these organizations who
may either choose not to become healthc
care providers at all or having become
them may choose not to work for those
kinds of organizations for these reasons
and so I'm asking if this bill doesn't
pass is that not something that would in
fact promote some of the staffing issues
that you're talking about so I'm on the
board of the New Hampshire Academy of
family physicians and we have an
advocacy committee that reviews all the
bills that are coming up and so when we
talked about this on our committee so
this is people with dozens and dozens of
years of Family Medicine experience all
of us were a little bit baffled by this
bill all of us thought why is this even
coming up this isn't an issue if you if
you object to something then you choose
a job where you don't do that and I
guess my my perspective would be that
that that is how things should remain
that if somebody is going to have an
objection in their conscience to a
certain job that might be required of
them then they they shouldn't take that
job right and that's and that's the way
it's always works so from a provider's
standpoint you know from a physician's
standpoint I just wouldn't take a job if
I had to do something that my conscious
objected to right I would choose a
different job and if you you know if you
are a you know a staff member who has an
objection to for example using blood
products then don't work in the ER or
the O right work someplace where you
don't have to give blood products so I
don't think that that's a very practical
reality that that our staffing problems
are coming from a lack of protection for
our
consciences representative pill I just
have a clarification issue are you
representing yourself or the New
Hampshire Association of family
practitioners because that's what you
put on your card is NH so I so I'm on
the I'm on the board for the new
Hampshire AFP and we discussed the
specific bill at our advocacy meeting so
I am speaking on their behalf thank you
yeah just thanks thank you any other
questions representative
trip thank you thank you Mr chair and
thank you for taking my question uh it
seems to me that
uh
uh a group of people that should be
involved in uh in this aren't uh because
the uh the people that operate the
ambulances if uh they're unaware that uh
certain Health Care Facilities will not
perform certain
uh uh things is this is this going to be
an issue here
too it certainly seems like it would
become an issue yeah if anyone's allowed
to object
followup uh it's it's not that I was
concerned about the the uh ambulance
operators themselves it's just that if
if they're not informed that certain
Health Care Facilities will not be will
not perform certain uh uh operations or
whatever you know if it's it seems like
it's a a bad idea for an ambulance to
show up and only then find out that the
uh Healthcare fac facility doesn't you
know and then the say like in in uh
Manchester you know there are options to
go to other healthc care facilities but
uh uh you know it's they say that they
say that time is crucial you know so
thank
you representative mayos thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question I wanted to ask you doctor
about the amendment which says the
section
um uh the section shall not apply to a
health care provider who is the only
health care provider present in an
emergency situation and you might have
heard me ask my question earlier about
who determines an emergency but I wanted
to ask you from your experience um in a
rural setting where there's only one
health care provider present in an
emergency situation and that healthc
care provider is objecting based on
conscience how in your experience would
that work yeah I appreciate that there's
an emergency Clause because that was my
first concern with this bill too was
thinking about you know the person who's
bleeding in the middle of the night who
needs their miscarriage taken care of
you know um and you can't always
anticipate that and so it may not be
your provider who has agreed that
they're going to take care of a patient
in any emergency it may be the scrub
tech who just got called in for the
night shift unexpectedly and that wasn't
wasn't planning on that you know um so I
think that an amendment would need to be
very fine-tuned and and well worded to
be adequate and to adequately cover that
but I think also as has been mentioned
what we've seen in other states with
Clauses like this is is that
unfortunately people get a little bit
touchy about it and a little scared when
they don't fully understand the
legalities and so I think that people
begin to limit care because they're
concerned about their legal exposure um
when bills like this are put into place
so that's I guess that's my concern is
that sort of down the road we see Ripple
effects um and those Ripple effects
would include having fewer and fewer
Healthcare Providers willing to do
procedures and having fewer and fewer
facilities that can maintain staff to do
those
procedures thank
you anyone any other
questions seeing none thank you thank
you so at this point I'm going to ask
the members if you have a question that
you need to ask to understand the bill
and make an informed decision by all
means ask it I'm going to have to limit
follow-ups at this point and uh limit
you to one opportunity to ask a question
but if you have a question ask it please
um we're an hour into this meeting
already and I'm not even halfway through
the card so I
just thank you Courtney Tanner
morning is this on now okay it is good
morning sorry about that for the record
Courtney Tanner I'm the senior director
of government relations at Dartmouth
health and um we have uh of course we
have a number of hospitals including
Dartmouth Hitchcock Medical Center up in
Lebanon but I think for the importance
of this bill it's also to important to
give you a little sense of our broader
footprint we also have um three other
New Hampshire Community Hospitals Al
pect in Lebanon New London Hospital in
New London and chesher Medical Center in
Kean we also have a number of outpatient
clinics including heer Road in Lebanon
we have clinics in conquer Manchester
and nashaa and the reason why I'm kind
of drawing out who we are and where we
are um is because I have some concerns
about the definitions of this bill and
the and the uh breath and the broadness
of this bill um we've talked you've
heard a lot about abortion today but
this bill doesn't just cover abortion it
also covers access to contraception um
prescription
medications and and uh other um uh
fertility services and so I just want to
note that um while we are a a proud
institution that does provide an array
of reproductive Health Care access we
also are providing contraceptive and
other um prescription medications in our
outpatient clinics too and so I have
concerns about this implicating all of
our uh clinics across the state I also
have grave concerns about page two lines
11 the definition of healthc care
provider that pretty much covers most of
if not all of our employees including
some of our outpatient retail pharmacies
um and any other PA professional so it's
been talked a little bit about in this
committee that this could be a person
who's just a person who's a scheduler
refusing to schedule a patient because
they have some concerns and what happens
to that patient they just fall away
there's no obligation to refer that um
patient to a different scheduler or
connect with um a a physician or a team
lead um so I have concerns about access
issues as as I look at that definition
of a healthc care
provider
um I also have concerns about uh the
Civil remedies protection there are um
while we always appreciate diversity of
thought I have concerns about how this
bill would interact with um ethical
obligations and with uh our existing
medical malpractice laws I suspect
there's somebody behind me that may talk
a little bit about that so I'll lead
that to to others but I do have concerns
about how we as an institution would
reconcile different standards if this
bill were were to be
passed um I'm happy to take take
questions I also know uh chairman that
you that you're running short on time
but I am happy to take questions as I
suspect there might be a few no I have
no problem with people asking questions
is just we want to limit the uh
follow-up system representative
Alexander thank you Mr chair thank you U
Miss Tanner for taking my question sure
um my question is primarily around um
Dartmouth health and and your network um
can you provide the committee data on
how many
sterilizations you engage in for miners
under the age of 18
um I'm not understanding the question
are you referring to a different a
specific
procedure um gender transition surgeries
I don't think that's relevant to the
bill I'm happy to have a conversation
with you offline but I'm I don't think
that's relevant to just to follow up it
this bill specifically mentions
sterilization treatment so that's why
I'm asking I think it's completely
relevant to the bill so Dartmouth health
does not perform surgeries for
individuals under minors one because
there's a bill that passed last legisl
session that prohibits um such care but
uh in even prior to last legislative
session Dartmouth health does not
perform um bottom surgeries for minors
who are seeking gender affirming care
surgeries thank you any other questions
of this witness representative tur yeah
just just one um if this were in place
would Dartmouth have concerns that the
actions of some of their employees could
leave your organization in violation of
the mtala rules yes I I would have
concerns about that I think as we talk
about our Workforce challenges it's come
up a lot in this hearing um one I want
to say as I was reviewing this this bill
we in New Hampshire and across the
country frankly are struggling for a
clinical Workforce certainly in Northern
New England and
um we there are not circumstances where
we are placing Med students or or
residents in situations where they feel
uncomfortable we want to have a complete
dialogue with with our Learners and with
providers to make sure that they're in
places that they feel comfortable and
they're going to be able to serve the
patients that they are signing up to
serve additionally as we think about um
some of our other Workforce challenges
in in our rural parts of the state I
think we have to be really careful about
striking a balance between um placing
civil remedies on institutions that may
um expose our institutions to risks and
allowing for an employer and employee
relationship to be amicable so that
employee employees feel comfortable
coming to their employers with concerns
about performing certain procedures or
questions about some of the work that's
being done at that respective
institution thank you representative
Pell thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question so if there's a
shortage of staff and you're concerned
about um attracting more healthcare
workers why wouldn't you be um
interested in entertaining a provider
who did have a conscientious objection
because that would add to your staff it
might give um an option for patients who
would be more comfortable with somebody
who didn't perform or prescribe certain
treatments that they were not
comfortable with themselves yeah I I
want to underscore we are uh we as an
institution respect and and appreciate
diversity of thought always and we want
to make sure that any provider that
wants to come and work at Dartmouth
Health feels comfortable in the service
that they want to be in and so I suspect
that there are certain providers that
might not want to be placed in OB cetric
but they might want to be placed in
Orthopedics or uh a different type of
service line and those conversations
should happen outside of legislation and
we would want that to happen with um the
institution and the provider themselves
without this looming uh threat of civil
remedies thank you representative
mayos thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question um I
I don't know whether you've seen the
amendment but it says that the section
shall not apply to a health care
provider who is the only care provider
present in an emergency situation and I
want to ask you as as Dartmouth health
and Dartmouth Hitchcock how would you
handle that situation if the only
provider is exercising their
conscientious objection who would decide
if it's an emergency situation and how
would that decision be made yeah so I I
don't have the amendment in front of me
I appreciate that there is an amendment
floating around so I've only heard about
it in concept um I appreciate that there
is an amendment that contemplates that
because that's one of our concerns and
our questions but I haven't seen the the
bill Tech so I would we do have concerns
about e access to emergency care if this
bill were to be um passed and I I the
bill is too broad I mean and we do need
to oppose the bill as drafted um and I
I'm not sure that there's work that
would bring this to a place where we
would be
comfortable thank you any other
questions of this witness seeing none
thank you if anyone has written
testimony even if it's just one sheet
that you want to turn in the clerk would
appreciate
that Courtney Reid
thank you chair for taking the time to
hear my testimony uh I've already passed
around a written copy of my remarks
ahead of uh the hearing but I just
wanted to note I'm passing around
testimony on behalf of new futures for
your review as well um for the record my
name is Courtney Reid I serve as policy
Advocate with the ACLU of New Hampshire
and I'm speaking in opposition to House
Bill
232 uh I just want to preface our
concerns with this bill by noting that
the ACLU throughout its history has
deeply valued religious liberty and has
consistently fought to uphold these
freedoms and uh values First Amendment
rights of expression and speech uh
however there are concerns that Bill
fails to balance uh these freedom of
speech and uh belief exercises with
existing federal and state law and
discrimination
protections uh in that it
would use the principle of religious
freedom to discriminate or deny crucial
services to individuals in
need and to dive into some of our
concerns of the bill and how this would
work in practice uh I want to Echo some
of remarks that we've heard before uh
from previous speakers that the broad
language of the bill and how it defines
health care provider or
participate suggests uh that it could
have a reaching impact Beyond simply
providing Medical Care again that this
could affect scheduling Pharmacy pickups
referrals or insurance coverage uh and I
want to note that uh although we haven't
seen the amendment that's floating
around uh that this exemption
for
emergencies really just wouldn't work in
practice especially considering this
broad scope of Provider uh I think it
should be uh a priority for the the
committee to concern how uh different
individuals that fall under the scope of
this definition really fail to uh
exercise the same degree of medical
judgment and discretion when it comes to
uh determining Emergency
Care um thank you
with that uh you know the definition of
abortion as it as it is in the bill uh
does have a carve out for ectopic
pregnancy but again uh there are many
other instances around the country where
we've seen restrictions on access to
abortion uh where health is in the line
and where seconds count and so these
alarming medical conditions uh like
hemorrhaging or sepsis uh really
cannot uh work with the language of the
bill as it as it is in its current state
and uh I just want to express that from
our previous hearings for example on HB
476 that Granite Staters really
understand the realities of medical
emergencies and they just do not uh look
favorably on barriers to the sensitive
care um with that there is also a
failure to consider instances of rape
incest or other life-threatening or
traumatic situations but uh beyond that
the license to discriminate would really
be felt more severely in rural areas of
the state where patients have a limited
choice in medical care uh and delays
brought on by travel or for waiting for
a deterioration of one's uh condition uh
would really result in irreparable harm
and just to talk about existing state
and federal
protections uh I think that this bill
really raised concerns about violating
different uh laws for example um
allowing for restrictions on abortion
narrower than our current state law the
bar on civil or criminal actions from
public officials um it is unclear in the
bill if this would go so far as to
prevent the AG the New Hampshire AG from
acting uh on a discrimination claim and
I also wanted to cite uh Mt
which is a federal law uh the emergency
treatment uh and Labor Act which
requires stabilization Transport
Services as well as title 9's healthc
Care Service uh provision and the
Affordable Care acts discrimination
protections just to name a few uh
Federal protections that I
think would be uh at risk of violation
under this law uh I also want to express
the New Hampshire state law has
discrimination protections that would be
undermined um and earlier I talked about
balancing discrimination protections
with religious freedoms RSA 354a does a
much better job at considering these
balances for example if you uh look at
uh
35415 regarding housing there is a
exemption for religious organizations
there uh as well as RSA
49122 that gives individuals a a cause
of action if their religious Liberties
have been
violated um broadening those protections
we also have constitutional Protections
in the 1 and 14th Amendment coupled with
uh title sevens uh reasonable
accommodations for employers we also
have legislation like the religious
freedom restoration act that requires
strict scrutiny to be applied before uh
any law is enacted that would burden
religious
freedoms and so I'm citing a lot of
things here but all of this is to say
that there are numerous state and
federal protections that are well
thought out and have been hard earned to
balance both of these Liberties and to
protect patients and medical providers
uh it is in our view that HB 232
undermines all of this work and
essentially would give clinicians a
blank check to violate these safeguards
uh at the cost of the health and
well-being of granite Staters even
jeopardizing Federal funding streams um
I have a few other notes in my testimony
and I'm happy to take questions
uh thank you so much are there any
questions of this
witness seeing none thank
you Jason Hennessy
thank you Mr chair honorable members of
the House Judiciary Committee thank you
for hearing my testimony my name is
Jason Hennessy I'm the president for New
Hampshire IDE to life I also have a PhD
in computational sciences and statistics
and we're here to
uh enthusiastically recommend that you
pass the
Bill many of you will remember the uh
the Chinese weager story where in
western China many uh Muslim Chinese
residents were put into re-education
camps and forced to eat um pork as part
of becoming more Mainline H Chinese now
when we hear this this is this is
grotesque because that's a huge
violation of their conscience
and I'm here to tell you that there are
many uh pro-life Healthcare
practitioners for whom having to do an
abortion or be fired is also a huge
violation in fact uh throughout most of
History including in the hypocritic oath
most many major religions have said that
this is
wrong and
so we want to we want to keep ethical
Health Care here in New Hampshire we
want to make sure our our practition are
not having to violate their conscience
in order just to keep their jobs article
four of the New Hampshire Constitution
declares that we have a right of
conscience and it's in
inalienable Article 5 similarly
guarantees religious freedoms and HB 232
upholds
these uh I want to I want to cite a uh
research letter from the uh Journal of
the American Med medical
association the most recent that I could
find and which says that's 4 States
explicitly
have uh protections for healthcare
practitioners and
conscience and of those one of them
Mississippi basically protects anything
that in your job that you have a
conscience for so basically 47 States
I've heard I've heard many
concerns uh that have been have been
spoken about here but I have not heard
really examples because if we have 47
states that have had these laws on the
books for many years you would think
there being plenty of examples to to
quote from I mean these are states like
California and New York Massachusetts
all of many of these have rural areas um
and and they don't have the the things
that people are asking for but we don't
have any examples not that I heard of
anyway now the question is do we need a
New Hampshire law uh we just heard that
there's federal laws that protect
conscience I want to draw your attention
to uh next door in Vermont who is one of
the other three states that does not
have a conscience law and and in there I
want to
quote from the uh at the University of
Vermont Medical Center a notice of
violation was issued by the federal HHS
office office of civil rights and they
reported that uh that UV MMC forced and
for forced the nurse complainant to
assist in an abortion against the
nurse's religious or moral objection the
nurse had expressed an objection for
many years and was included in a list of
objectors but UV MMC knowingly assigned
the nurse to an abortion procedure
the nurse was not told the procedure was
an abortion until the nurse walked into
the room when the doctor knowing that
the nurse
objected told the nurse don't hate
me the nurse again objected and other
staff who were uh present who could have
taken the nurse's place but the nurse
was required to
assist uh another another article
reports that the nurse left that
position and has been traumatized ever
since I want to draw your attention to
this because you might think well
federal law is going to cover it because
you know DHHS came in and the doj came
in but it turns out that once the
administration switched over in 2021 all
of this went away all the all the
charges were dropped that's why we need
a New Hampshire law we cannot depend on
the federal government to uphold
conscience rights and we have to do it
here at the state level and this isn't
just other states um if you go to the
Dartmouth Hitchcock web page uh on their
policies for OBGYN residents they
require their residents to actually
refer for abortion even if it's against
their
conscience so this is not a theoretical
issue this is an issue that is happening
here and
now and this is just what's on the web
right there's there's probably all sorts
of stories that are not are not there
and a reference to this is in my my
testimony that you're welcome to look up
last week this committee also heard on
the hearing for HP 476 that we have uh
severe
shortages well keep in mind that the
number of OBGYNs that actually do
abortions is in the single digits
according to according to one
survey if that's the case that means
that the vast majority do not perform
abortions and so if we want to recruit
from the from the vast majority of them
having conscience Protections in place
is
required and I'll also share that I am
aware of at least one Dartmouth medical
school graduate who was familiar with
the policies at Dartmouth and refuse to
stay here for residency because of those
abortion
policies but that's but other people who
are coming into the state from out of
state may not be familiar with that they
may not read all the
details finally I want to address uh
some of the things I heard here and uh
and talk about what happen has happened
in other states first that this might
apply to receptionists first off the
idea that we would not give nurses AIDS
or
other staff who don't happen to have the
the education qualifications of other
staff conscience protection is um is
insane in my mind people should be able
to follow their
conscience and by the way at least 34
States including places like New York
don't limit the conscience protections
to only certain staff they basically say
healthcare
workers secondly you heard that somebody
might decide on the spot that they have
Healthcare object or they have a
conscience
objection well States like California
and Massachusetts only require a written
objection they don't say how early you
have to put it in New York's law only
requires prior written refusal with no
definition of
prior again if this was an issue you
would think that there would be stories
that we'd be hearing from other
states um other so New York and
Massachusetts for example have no new
emergency exceptions although we do
support having an emergency
exception and and we are very familiar
with many pro-life healthcare workers
and we are not aware of any who would
not work to save the life of a
mother and that is the I guess the last
comment I'll make is in terms of rural
care um amongst the 47 other states that
have conscience protection there are
many rural States in there um California
Massachusetts New York all have large
rural areas and we haven't heard
anything about uh conscience rights
interfering with the treatment of women
and with that I would be happy to take
any questions any questions of this
witness representative
McFarland in both your verbal and your
written testimony you talk about this uh
interpretation that so much as making a
referral would in fact
be performing an abortion or a
sterilization or an artificial
contraception I I imagine that um that
is not something that some folks
understand readily can you help us
understand what the case law is that
supports that
conclusion that a that a referral would
would be a conscientious objection that
the performance of an appropriate
referral is in and of itself the
performance of the
act so my understanding is that there
are a number of of phys s who very much
object to abortion they believe it to be
murder and the idea that you would help
somebody obtain that would be in itself
unconscionable may I have a
followup yes do you believe then that a
patient who goes to such a physician if
they were given the right to object for
these
reasons and is unable to be satisfied in
in their purposes for going to that pH
position should be charged for the
services if I can if I can better
understand your question representative
you're you're
saying can they charge for a service so
suppose I go to a GP and I say I have
several you know things I want to
address and and these items are one of
them and that physician then says I I am
neither going to take care of you nor
make a referral are you saying that that
the hospital organization should still
charge for that service or should that
service be null and void thank you for
the question representative one of the
things I know is that I do not
understand medical billing so I don't
feel like I could answer that
question thank
you any other questions seeing none
thank you thank you Miss
Mr Holly is it Holmes hes
thank you chairman Manion and members of
the committee for allowing me to speak
today my name is Holly Haynes I'm an
attorney at Abramson Brown and Dugan in
Manchester New Hampshire and I'm a past
president of the New Hampshire
Association for justice and I'm here to
speak today in opposition of House Bill
232 you've heard a lot I submitted I
previously submitted written test
testimony that I think outlined the over
breadth that's been addressed by many
other people at this hearing um it's
extremely over Broad in
scope this bill has been brought at
least twice before and I think it's been
deemed inexpedient to legislate each
time I hope that it reaches the same
fate during this
session the New Hampshire Association
for justice strongly feels that this is
a solution in search of a problem it's
not something that is necessary
as representative
McFarland recognized federal law already
protects against discrimination for
employment
disputes our biggest concern as an
organization is the broad immunity that
it grants to Health Care Providers if
someone is harmed because of a
provider's exercise of their right of
conscience as this committee knows the
New Hampshire Constitution guarantees
every citizen of the state a right to a
remedy our Supreme Court has found that
while not fundamental it is an important
substantive right and there are very few
immunities allowed in state law even the
state of New Hampshire has waved its
sovereign immunity which is perhaps the
most important that we know when a state
actor harms a
citizen if a healthc care provider
exercises their right to
conscience that shouldn't alleviate them
from their responsibility for any harm
that they cause to a
patient we've heard about the emergency
issues that may come up there are other
times when people may require
sterilization for breast cancer or for
other cancers when they need to have
their ovaries removed sterilization
encompasses decisions for vasectomy for
men it encompasses as many things this
isn't just an abortion bill when we're
dealing with rights of
conscience in addition to the broad
immunity that this is given it's taking
away patients rights of action
and it's a very slippery slope as well
if we think of how far this can go if
this bill is passed the right of
conscience can be extended to many other
things it can be extended to allow
Healthcare Providers to ignore do not
resuscitation orders of
patients if the rights of conscience
bill is passed it could be extended in
the future to allow providers to choose
not to
prescribe medications if they oppose
them this is a slippery slope for the
future and it's something that I think
requires a lot of consideration before
it should ever come to
fruition and finally the bill itself is
internally inconsistent and while it
protects the healthcare provider's right
of conscience it completely ignores All
rights of
patients in section E3 the notice
requirement I think representative
McFarland recognized this the notice is
for healthc care providers it's not
notice to the patients patients are
never going to be notified if a provider
is exercising their right of conscience
especially if it's someone a scheduling
clerk in an OBGYN office when someone
calls to schedule an appointment to
discuss contra
exception the patient will never get
notice of this it's nice that the
provider will have notice that they
can't be discriminated against but the
patient never going to have notice that
providers are allowed to exercise their
right of
conscience the other internal
inconsistency is that this is giving
providers their own cause of action to
sue it provides them with civil remedies
it allows them to Super for damages if
they're discriminated against for
exercising the right of conscience but
at the same time it's taking away the
right of the patient to sue for damages
or to have a civil remedy if the
provider exercises their right of
conscience you can't have it both ways
you can't give the provider a right that
you're taking away from the patient
that's just not fair in practice it
can't happen and I would hope that this
committee would deem this inexpedient to
legislate I'm happy to take any
questions you may have any questions of
this witness representative Oregan
um this may be this may be a good
question for you because um you're
obviously you wouldn't be here if you
weren't a uh very if you weren't like a
lawyer is very well respected by your
fellow trial fellow lawyers and also uh
obviously studied the whole thing in
great detail but one thing I've noticed
it seems to me maybe I'm right or wrong
and I don't know whether the dep of
healthc care provider excludes um
so-called Pregnancy Crisis centers which
I guess probably wouldn't ever be
encouraging people to have abortions but
you know they might be
encouraging uh the young women who are
there to uh take advantage of some of
the other services which this bill
covers so is that uh so do you do you
feel that do you think the bill is
written um does it does it in fact as I
seem to read it exclude such pres such
centers or are they included in that
definition
or I don't think that I looked that
closely at it and I'm sorry
okay yeah that's just over a global okay
just thought i' just thought I'd ask in
case you had a thought but thank don't
but did but thank thanks for your
excellent excellent
presentation seeing none thank you thank
you very
much Patrick
hedger Patrick
hedger oh this is on another bill
apparently oh I'm not keeping you
organized no that that was my fault
anyways I have no more pink cards on
this bill is there anyone here that
hasn't turned one in that is to speak on
House Bill
232 seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing on House Bill
232 I'm going to open up the hearing on
HB 253 and I'm going to recess that the
uh Prime sponsor had to step away to
introduce another
bill um and now I'm going to
open time certain you can
say
um 1145 so House Bill 253 we recessed to
11:45
now I'm going to open the hearing on
House Bill
and Shuffle it around a little bit right
there she is there she is and I
recognize representative dry to
introduce the bill
representative beron could I have you
change the number on the sign to
293 thank you
I thought it was more of a camera
concern
is that what you're
suggested where does it
go great you should put it on both
sides
good set okay thank
you you're all set to introduce
representative thank you Mr chairman and
thank you committee for hearing this
this bill for the record my name is
representative Margaret dry I serve
Sullivan district 7 which is Charlestown
Newport unity planfield and
Cornish I heard a really disturbing fact
last summer at a conference that 40% of
America's 9 to 11 year olds had been
exposed to hardcore
pornography it bothered me so much that
I jumped at the chance to sponsor a bill
like one in Louisiana that required age
verification before a user could access
a porn site 19 states have passed that
age verification law
however in um one of them Free Speech
Coalition versus Paxton is presently
before the United States Supreme Court
uh to determine if it undermines free
speech this Judiciary Committee actually
last year had a similar bill on age
verification uh and it was voted in
expedient to
legislate uh the paragraph in the house
calendar that described it had three
problems with that bill one it was easy
to get around uh age verification
digitally because of uh V virtual
private networks VPN um the similar Bill
the Paxton bill was headed towards the
Supreme Court to see if it was VI in the
First Amendment and the Attorney General
was mentioned in the bill but nobody had
consulted the Attorney
General so an alternate Bill one that
used a filter on electronic devices
seemed like a better approach uh justice
Kennedy and ashc uh in 2002 gave this
advice he said filters are less
restrictive they impose selective
restrictions on speech at the receiving
end not Universal restrictions at the
source
so this bill or one very much like the
one you have before you today was passed
in Utah last year and took effect on
January 1st
2025 one of the first things I did when
I got a copy of the bill that was passed
in Utah was to send it on to our own
attorney general for consultation the
bill before you has been adjusted to
refer to New Hampshire
statutes and it has basically six
sections very briefly I just want to
point out the first section adds
um amends the consumer expectation of
privacy act that's what 507 DH colon 4
is to assume that the manufacturer of
the device will have a filter on the
device then it moves on to a lot of
definitions the one that's probably the
most important on there is uh Roman
numeral 8 which says obscene material
that references R RSA 650 colon 1
um the device filter is required in the
next section uh there will be more
explanation from that from other people
today if there
is this that requires a filter on the
devices made by put there by the
manufacturer the retailer has nothing to
do with this it's just the
manufacturer there's a private right of
action for parents if the Mach if the
device does not have a filter and they
expected it or if uh someone has
intentionally or unintentionally
disabled the filter and their minor was
exposed to
pornography um the next section is the
consumer protection act this is where
our attorney general would get in um
into the mix basically if the device
says it has a filter it's required to
have a filter and it does not that's an
area for the Attorney General to
investigate finally there's criminal
liability for disabling the filter if
you are not the parent or the guardian
um and then um sets the the details for
that it's a very simple bill it moves
along pretty well and and it has been
looked at with a number of eyes but I
want to tell you why this bill is
important it's because families can
control access on devices there are
parents that can do this they can set it
up
most of the time they say it's extremely
complicated but they can still set it up
but they can't control what their
children's friends parents do so why
don't we set the safety as our default
so to protect young eyes make them all
safe and then adults can disable the
filter as they see fit on their own
devices
finally um this has met all the qualif
the problems that you saw last year in
an age verification bill I believe it's
a better Bill and reports from Utah
after their law has been in effect for
more than a month is that there have
been no problems with its implementation
and I'm asking you to vote this bill
ought to pass thank you and I'm open to
any questions I have one question uh so
this filter of something that's already
in place it wouldn't be something
manufacturers would have to have time to
work the build it's already there thank
you for the question yes I was amazed
and pleased to know that they're already
there it's really just a matter of
extending it to the the right age thank
you representative Oregon um this is
have a question about one detail in the
bill which is um in um your proposed
uh 50 507 the definitions Roman numeral
7 so it says minors include means under
age of 18 okay that makes sense but then
you throw in it's not emancipated
married or member of the Armed Forces
the United States I'm not exactly sure
why if someone is uh enlisted in the
Armed Force why it's any less dangerous
for them to be viewing this material and
same applies probably for those other
two categories so why is why is it why
is it not dangerous for a teenager to
see this Museum this material if they're
you know if they're in the service or
but it's okay if if they're if they're
why is it okay for them if they're in
the service but like if they're a
civilian they can't see it and likewise
representative um that is already in the
law and there are a number of places in
New Hampshire statute where that
triumphant of over 18 or emancipated or
member of the AR active duty member of
the Armed Forces counts as an
adult any other questions representative
tur yeah thank you and thanks for taking
the question so you start off talking
about the fact that the prior law that
was itl uh focused on age verification
and that this law doesn't but but this
law does invoke age as a key requirement
and as far as I see the only provision
for how that's enforced is it ask the
user to provide their age when they set
up their account so is this basically
not even addressing the question of age
verification essentially saying it it
you know that corporations could be put
in violation of Consumer Protections
without any way to sort of uh certify
that the person that they are showing
material to would qualify okay thank you
for the question let me ask that the age
verification process is what we're
talking about not just age verification
the process that had the other Bill had
was you had to submit a driver's license
or something you had to give your
information and be checked to me whether
you were 18 or older so even if you were
an adult you are exposing all your
information to this company uh this is
done when you buy the device and
register and activate it it's done and
will then the M they will recognize that
the person who whose device it is is
under 18 there will be a password so
that somebody over 18 the parents that
get the password can change it so that
it acts as a normal device for them it's
just when it's registered the when the
password is activated it would notice
that you were not there did De retail
people are not involved in it and there
is if you notice there um if the
manufacturer
um believes that they have tried to meet
the criteria then then they wouldn't be
charged for that if they if they've done
their best to make sure that the filter
is in place sorry one quick followup
could you could you point me to the
sorry could you point me to the place
where in the law where it says that that
that there are these these protections
and exemptions because I'm not totally
clear who would perform this this
verification function okay um if you
look on um page three uh lines 23 to 26
manufacturer that does not comply can be
subject to action by the attorney
general that the manufacturer reasonably
believed based on its demonal efforts to
comply with the law that the device did
simply did comply with the provisions
should be an absolute defense to any
violation brought according to this
section and the line Right Above It 21
no cause of action shall exist against a
retailer represent
McFarland thank you and uh
representative I apologize I missed the
the starting part of your testimony I
thought we were doing 253 before yours
but uh um I I read this bill carefully
and uh to representative T's
question uh I do see the section in
there that you talk about uh that
protects the manufacturers or purports
to protect the manufacturers as long as
they comply with the other part of your
bill with r RSA 507 uh dasi colon 2
however the way that that language is
structured is language which um if I
understand correctly and I would
appreciate your your confirming or or
clarifying for me uh would in fact
compel uh a whole raft of Manufacturers
be it car manufacturers laptop
manufacturers and other manufacturers to
take actions which are technically
impossible and uh which you know when
you talk about these filters would in
fact not achieve the ends that you're
asking for because they could readily be
uh bypassed by a juvenile in any event
is that correct um I'm thank you for the
question I'm trying to imagine what a
car manufacturer would have to change so
there are a lot of cars nowadays that
have internet access built into them as
an example
um I think i' you've reached the part
where I'm a little not as technically
inclined as I would need to answer that
question but I can find out the answer
for you thank
you are there any other questions
representative uh
Smith thank you very much perhaps I've
missed a section can you show me where
um it says in here that the parent has
some
responsibility uh if you go towards the
end of the
bill um the it's about disabling the
device so so it will set up the parent
has the
password it will be uh assume that it is
set to 18 and uh that uh anybody or
under 18 what and that's the beginning
what line is that all right
well are you looking for when they set
it up how it's done or no I'm looking at
what the
responsibility I'm sorry I'm looking at
the responsibility of a parent obviously
I you know I'm showing my age um because
I you know I raise children and
grandchildren with devices that had on
and off switches and I had the
responsibility and so I'm just curious
about um where in this it says that the
parent has a responsibility to ensure
that the um minor is uh not exposed to
material
uh that is prohibited under this
proposal okay so take a look at um page
two yep starting at um let's start with
22 the filters uh line 32 the filter is
required so it has to contain a filter
32 line 32 33 okay I see contains a
filter asks the user to provide the age
automatically enables it gives the
password it establishes the password
that's given to the parents he notifies
the user of the device when the filter
blocks something from a website and um
it will allow a non-minor user that's
the parent who has the password the
option to activate or deactivate or
reactivate the filter right below that
is the parent or legal guardian may
bring a civil action against anybody who
intentionally disables this or um the
manufacturer if the filter which they
thought existed did not exist um that's
their right of action on this at the
very end um it does at the line 32 on
page three it talks about disabling an
electronic device for the purpose of
allowing access to obscene material and
minor
is a crime and if the minor does in fact
access obscene material it's a class B
felony if just if can I just clarify
would that be okay M yes so um if a
parent then in this uh the last section
that you uh noted um were to
disable the electronic device then um
who would bring the the charge of
criminal liability against the
parent probably somebody who knows about
it thank you very
much representative Perez thank you
thanks for taking I'm G I look at this a
little bit like like when I turn on the
TV and it says recommended not
recommended for under
14 I have a choice of either
allowing my Min or not minor child my
minor child to watch it or
not um are you saying that this would be
the same idea that if I if a um a parent
had a minor child bought the device
registered the device as the child's
device okay and if the parent chose to
disable that could the parent be
prosecuted for that well I just want to
remind you all that it is a crime to
show that um obscenity defined by our
rsas to a minor okay thank you that's
what I needed to clarify so um it's pre
preventing the parent as well as another
individual from allowing this type of
thing to happen yes thank you thank you
representative
trip thank you Mr chair uh thank you for
taking my question
uh I I notice on uh in the section that
says filter required is that uh all
devices uh shall contain when activated
in the state shall contain a
filter uh
so the uh the issue here is uh any
device it being either a uh a tablet or
a smartphone will have to have the
software installed
uh already has the filter installed just
needs to change the parameters on the
filter did that answer your
question thank
you any other questions from somebody
who hasn't asked a question
already we need to move along here so um
thank
you have you asked a question already
representative sh
yes okay thank you thank you thank you
yes so at this point I have a lot of
cards on this and we are really behind
on hearings today so we're going to
limit testimony to 3 minutes strictly so
tailor your testimony to 3 minutes if
you have written testimony that will be
helpful to turn in and uh I'm going to
call Representative uh Michael Aaron
thank you committee members for taking
my testimony my name is Michael Aaron
I'm representing uh Sullivan County
District 8 which is nine towns I won't
go into the
list I am going to tell you a little
story to to illustrate why this bill is
necessary I know a young woman who was
about 12 years old and she wanted to buy
some athletic wear and decided to go to
the Dicks Sporting Goods website to
check out
prices you can see where this is
going she did not know the website name
and typed in something else and was very
surprised and traumatized when the
website that she did pull up came up uh
so I believe that if uh filters like the
the filters being requested in this bill
were in place on her device she would
not have been traumatized by going to a
pornographic website by
mistake uh that's really my whole story
and I'll be happy to answer
questions thank you representative
McFarland thank you representative uh M
Mr chairman I I was struggling to
understand the intent of the the prime
sponsor and as you are one of the
co-sponsors sir perhaps you could help
explain that intent a little further in
the
context of knowing that parents and
Guardians have the opportunity to choose
to provide or withhold access uh by the
child by the minor to a device to choose
a device that has parental controls
available and Implement those parental
controls um to place restrictions on the
the network and internet access that
they connect that device to and so forth
can you explain to me therefore what the
intent of this bill is that is
additional to the the choice Avail
already available uh to those parents
and Guardians thank you for that
question I believe that uh the filtering
or the parental controls are already on
those devices they're just not turned on
by default and the purpose of this bill
is to make sure that that is turned on
by default rather than off uh some of
these uh parental controls uh especially
on some newer devices are really
difficult to navigate through the
settings and so if it's turned on by
default uh it'll be there and does not
rely on the parents uh expertise or non-
expertise about using the device uh to
get it turned on
thank you representative rbo thank you
Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question
um I as a parent with kids who have
trying to listen to music on devices and
working with these filters myself I can
understand the challenges of of getting
them right um and we certainly had
instances where um like a Broadway
musical we wanted to listen to as a
family had some swear words in it and so
the filter blocked it from me played
until we you know made decisions about
what to do with the filters um the
if I'm understanding correctly the
automatic filter being proposed here are
the same filters that right now would be
the same as what exists or would they
somehow
um change the way the the kind of
filters you're able to have or how you
negotiate the filters as a parent I
don't believe that they would be any
different than what is on the phone now
device not on a on a particular platform
right smartphone
laptop uh tablet whatever uh there are
settings for parental controls uh to to
let you know what kind of websites you
can filter out and uh they're just not
turned on okay so it doesn't fix the pro
the challenges of the filters themselves
it just automatically sets that on
correct thank you any other
questions seeing none thank you thank
you representative Judy Aon
good morning chair Manion and members of
the
committee excuse me for the record my
name is representative Judy Aaron I
represent the uh towns of aworth Goan
langon lemster and Washington in sullan
County District 4 I'm here today um as a
co-sponsor the bill and uh I am going to
read a statement from uh a woman who was
unable to attend uh this hearing this
morning as she is contracted norovirus
and wasn't able to be here so I'm just
going to say um this is for Bella
parachi from Stratham New Hampshire
she's a P public policy research
associate with the national Center on
sexual exploitation an organization
dedicated to combating all forms of
sexual exploitation and abuse and she's
asking you all to support HB 293 uh this
bill is a vital step in protecting
Granite State's children from exposure
to harmful and dangerous material online
just as we require car manufacturers to
include seat belts and cars this bill
simply asks us to add seat belts for our
browsers an extra layer of protection
for Children online we're living in an
era of unprecedented technological
advancement growing up uh parents told
us how to stay safe on the internet
don't talk to people you don't know
online don't post anything you might
regret keep your accounts private and so
on I've uh she stayed true to her
parents
rules and even though she's done
everything she can to protect herself
online you still have been exposed to
have seen content unintentionally
children are just a click or a scroll
away from being exposed to such content
and viewing such material is becoming
increasingly normalized
the effects of early exposure to
pornography on young minds is well
documented a Common Sense Media survey
cont conducted in 2022 found that 75% of
boys and 70% of girls age 13 to 17 has
consumed pornography within that group
of children 15% first saw pornography at
10 years old or younger and 54% at 13
years old or younger this material often
depicting disturbing content such as
sexual assault violence and aggression
influences the way children perceive and
process these behaviors and as they
consume and internalize this content its
impact becomes evident Heidi Olen a
sexual assault nurse examiner at a large
Children's Hospital explains that
children age 11 to 15 have been the
largest group of sexual assault
perpetrators at her facility for the
third consecutive year and research
demonstrates the strong correlation
between porn porography sex trafficking
and sexual exploitation pimps and
traffickers often use sexually explicit
material to groom children until the
sexual aggression becomes
normalized last year the national Center
for missing and exploited children cyber
tip line receive
45000 time limit yes okay you can wrap
up with a sentence I would appreciate
that um sure um you
know one way to protect children is by
making it harder for them to access
sexually explicit material
which is the purpose of this bill every
phone comes pre-loaded with existing
filtering software this bill simply
requires manufacturers to turn these
filters on by default thank you very
much and you have written testimony
testimony thank so much appreciate that
thank
you representative uh
merer hello again
thank you Mr chair and honorable members
of the committee for the record again my
name is Lisa merer I represent Hillsboro
District 44 Goffstown and wear um also I
am a co-sponsor on the bill I am here to
express my strong support for HB 293 FN
aimed at preventing minors from
accessing obscene content on electric
electronic devices with internet access
this issue is one of great concern not
only for the saf and well-being of our
children but also for the healthy
development of their minds and Futures
as we all know the internet is an
invaluable tool that has transformed how
we learn communicate and interact
however with this access comes a
significant risk the easy availability
of harmful and obscene material Studies
have shown that exposure to such content
at a young age can have detrimental
effects on minors including distorted
views on relationship sexuality and
self-image as well as increased
vulnerability to exploitation it could
also leave to very unsafe situations
some may argue that s such restrictions
could infringe upon personal freedom or
hinder the open nature of the internet
however there is a clear difference
between promoting open access to
information and allowing unrestricted
access to content that is harmful to
minors it could even lead children into
being sex trafficked and other dangerous
situations parents and Guardians should
be empowered to make informed decisions
about their children's online activities
and this bill supports their ability to
do so it is not about limiting access to
knowledge or entertainment but about
ensuring that children are protected
from content that could and will cause
irreversible harm in closing I urge this
body to pass this bill to protect the
well-being of our children and to ensure
that the internet remains a safe place
for for Learning and growth we have a
collective responsibility to safeguard
the mental health of future generations
and this bill is a critical part of that
effort I won't be taking questions today
because there are people in this room
who are far far more knowledgeable about
this than I am but I am in full support
I do have to run to another hearing I
apologize but thank you for hearing us
today thank
you Barbara patch
hello chairman Lynn members of the
committee I'm Barb patch and I'm here as
the Director of all girls Aloud a
nonprofit that fights exploitation every
single day and also representative of
the New Hampshire traffic free
Coalition we like HB 293 because it's a
very straightforward and easy to
implement the filtering technology that
we're asking to default to on for miners
already exists on the devices this would
relieve a huge burden that's currently
placed on the shoulders of parents to
protect children from obscene content
and it has a huge payoff as you've
already heard a little bit of for the
protection of our children's brains and
their
future many of us have grandchildren
nieces nephews daughters sons who Among
Us in this room would ever take a child
to the edge of the red leg district and
drop them off and say go
play if we give them one of these that's
exactly what we're doing every
day without intentionally searching for
it children can ex experience porn just
a few clicks away as you've already
heard testified to in her article I had
a helicopter Mom I found porn anyway
this was published in August 2023
Isabelle hogman wrote I was 10 years old
when I watched porn for the first time I
found myself on PornHub which I stumbled
across by accident and returned to out
of curiosity the site is easy to find
impossible to avoid and has become a
frequent white right of passage for kids
my age where was my mother she was in
the Next Room making sure I was eating
nine different colored fruits and
vegetables on The Daily she was
attentive nearly a helicopter parent but
I found porn anyway and so did my
friends
first let's get on the same page about
what porn really is today when I talk to
adults I get the strong sense that they
picture a hot bombshell in lingerie or a
half- naked model on the beach that's
not what I stumbled upon back in the
fourth grade I saw simulated incest
beastiality extreme bondage sex with
unconscious women gang bangs satom
masochism and Unthinkable physical
violence the porn children View today
makes Playboy look like an American Doll
catalog that's what we're dealing with
we are also seeing um individual stories
you've heard already but large scale
negative outcomes when children are
exposed to porn children who VI view
pornography are three times more likely
to be sexually exploited and porn
exposure is fueling massive increases in
child-on-child sexual abuse as you've
already heard in a study at the UK where
they're very well
Advanced interviews apologize that's
your that's your time limit if you can
wrap up with a sentence yep we feel that
there's a huge Risk by not having these
filterings on today any child could walk
into a bookstore and that bookstore
would make sure that that child is not
exposed to pornography or obscene
material yet why do we allow that to
happen online we urge you to pass this
Bill thank you representative Alexander
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question I guess your last statement
confused me because this bill is
directed to the
manufacturers not the retailers right
but you just gave me a situation of the
retailers blocking the access to this
obscenity I understand that this is a
this is an issue and we should you know
government has an interest in protecting
miners
but should we go after the magazine
manufacturers
too we don't need to go it it's it's not
it's the concept behind the
issue right now the the burden is 100%
on the shoulders of the parent to
protect the children many of the parents
in our state are in foster homes they do
not have an parent and even you heard
the testimony very involved parent that
was unable to um set all the appropriate
filters and even know that that's going
on new parents aren't even aware of the
risks and so we would like to see our
state take responsibility to help block
this putting it on the manufacturers
levels very easy to implement and it's
an easy way to get that done so you know
why do we allow this you know however it
gets done they can't walk into a
bookstore and get it so why should they
be able to get
online representative pz thank you
thanks for taking my question um what's
to stop my child from going into the
library and using the library computer
or will we be able to make sure that
schools are using this same type of of
uh filter in the you know the schools
because I know right now many schools
are saying and I know this as a fact
well we can't do that we can't do we
have the question oh yes will we be able
to implement this in schools and librar
so children aren't AB thank you for the
question um we don't believe this bill
is going to solve every exposure issue
however we do believe it would yes in
schools when they get devices now if
they're activated in the state of New
Hampshire these filters would be turned
on for ages 17 and under yeah
representative
Smith thank you um could you um on page
two Romans 6 material means any Printed
Matter visual representation goes on and
on and on uh including but not limited
to books magazines films pamplets
records
um can you tell me how
we would have a filter on Printed Matter
P we would not be able to have a filter
on Printed Matter yeah so I'm not
entirely sure how this particular bullet
point relates to the rest of the bill
but what we're asking for here is on the
internet device whatever they are able
to find on here so it could be a picture
a picture of printed M material
potentially um I don't know enough about
this but I can find out for you could be
but I think that's a definition already
in statute of material that's why it's
it's worded that way it already exists
that that definition so representative
McFarland thank you Mr
chairman if I understand you correctly
um you are looking to place this burden
on the manufacturers as representative
Alexander outlined could I understand
then given that those manufacturers
would in order for this to to be
effective require to support these
filters and these these Technologies for
the duration of the effective use of the
device by the miners uh or by anyone
could could you help me understand how
long you contemplate that a manufacturer
selling a a tablet or a smartphone in
this state would require to support that
device and would it be true that after
that point that that device would
require to be bried by the manufacturer
so that it couldn't be further
used um these device these filters are
already on there so for example if you
have an iPhone already if your child is
12 years old or younger and you activate
your device for that child those filters
are turned on so what we're asking is a
very simple matter of extending the age
that that happens and if there's devices
where that filtering has not been turned
on by default that it would be turned on
um we do believe that these devices we
all know we get the updates right that
come nightly or whatever whenever they
come that they would be there for the
life of that and then once the device is
deactivated the manufacturer is no
longer required to support those filters
um for the new
person thank you representative trip
thank you Mr chair uh fairly simple
question so these filters are provided
at no cost on the cell phones and the
tablets
correct any other questions
representative T just to clarify are we
talking about what's called the safe
search uh switch on on a browser is that
what the filter technology that we're
talking about is it consistant right
there we actually have a technical
expert who's going to be talking more
about it but we're we're actually
talking much larger than that there are
these things called spiders that
evaluate web content so when you do a
user does a search it will evaluate all
the material and the words to determine
using AI is there obscene material
coming across and that's what would be
blocked
the user would then get an indicator
that this is blocked content so the
parent doesn't have to take the burden
of turning it off everywhere that's what
we're going for here thank you any other
questions seeing none thank you all
right thank you so much I appreciate
your time Rick forio
chair Manion and Judiciary members thank
you for allowing me to give a quick
testimony today uh I am again Rick
fabrio senior director of advocacy and
public affairs for the business and
industry Association uh Bia understands
the importance of uh restricting miners
access to obscene material such as
pornography it's not uh unlike uh proper
protocols to assure miners can't buy
alcohol and tobacco uh but 293 is flawed
on multiple FR fronts with the most
important being that it exposes device
manufacturers and operating system
manufacturers to unfair unreasonable and
misguided civil liability the best way
to keep miners uh from accessing obscene
material pral and guardian involvement
in the use of read readily available
content blockers for devices and
operating systems uh internet browsers I
mean um but 293 creates unworkable
requirements uh devices and operating
systems are not manufactured to meet
individual state laws and the desired
level of filtering is not
technologically feasible part of that is
because of the inclusion as we've
discussed books magazines and extensive
list um and while the language the
closest it gets to pornography saying
pornography is the line that depicts or
describe sexual conduct in a manner so
explicit as to be patently false however
it includes other definitions that are
subjective such as ludin or lascivious
thoughts when applying contemporary
standards if there's a clearness in
there I've yet to find it and I don't I
just don't see that and that's important
given the inclusion of civil liability
up to $100,000 and punitive damages in a
private right of action uh the goal
should be provide proper safeguards not
to Pro uh prompt a slew of civil actions
that could be very costly to
manufacturers of both the operating
systems and devices I'm happy to take
any
questions any questions repr
representative
McFarland thank you Mr chairman um Mr
frbo am I right in understanding that if
I have a tablet such as my car or a
smartphone such as my
laptop and I was see to seek to
reinstall the operating system on that
or to uh install an open source
operating system on that that under this
bill I would be a
felon there are felony charges if you
deactivate a this filter for and then a
minor uses it another problem with this
bill is that devices um are manufactured
packaged wrapped and sent uh if they
went to the default filter that it's on
for you know miners um that still would
require the purchaser of the device to
take it home and start it up and then if
choose to deactivate they would have to
show some type of age verification but I
don't see language in here that explains
how age would be verified thank you any
other
questions representative mayos thank you
Mr chair thank you for taking my
question um page two line five the
bill um includes an obscenity or it it's
actually under the definition of
material it says undeveloped photograph
graphs molds printing plate printing
plates and the like shall be deemed
obene material not withstanding that
processing or other acts may be required
to make the obscenity patent or to
disseminate it and I'm wondering if you
have any concerns about that language in
the bill oh I'm broadly concerned about
that whole uh definition of obene
materials because of the inclusion of
all the different mediums but also what
are contemporary standards and while
there may be another law that offers
something like that it still in my
opinion would expose uh would create
liability um and it's it feels a lot
like for a bill where there's been a lot
of testimony about
pornography there's not language in here
strictly focused on pornography and
obscene material can be highly subed to
individuals thank you are there any
other
questions seeing none thank you thank
you Trisha
Eastman hello chairman chairman and
members of the committee my name is
Trisha Eastman I am an educated middle
class professional mom to three boys I
here today to provide a personal
testimony on why I'm in support of this
bill in 2020 my sons were given um
Chromebooks for school my middle son at
the age of nine innocently was searching
for things online and came across
obscene
material I put on filters on our
internet providers Wi-Fi as well as took
their computers and tried to put blocks
on whatever I could part of the problem
was not having a technical background
and not growing up in computers as our
kids are um it caused things to be
blocked that they needed for school so I
often had to remove those so that they
could access school and in fact allowing
him to have access to obscene
material jump forward to
2024 my now 14-year-old son is addicted
to
pornography we are a very um
unusual family where we limit screen
time we do not allow our kids on
anything with Wi-Fi or Internet access
um willy-nilly like it's limited and
monitored we went as far as to lock up
Electronics he found ways to get on and
to access this things came to a head
when I learned from my 12-year-old son
that the 14-year-old had gone on a um
chat live stream pornography site and
was
chatting with
people this terrified me I was scared
that he would be trafficked or meet up
with someone not even to mention the
long-term effects of this addiction to
pornography in his personal
relationships as an
adult because I felt like I could no
longer provide the level of care that
was needed for him I chose to send him
to a residential treatment center where
he spent 45 days came home for about 45
days got on another device actually at
school which is supposed to have go
guardian and found ways around and got
on some more chat
websites I then sent him back he is now
home after being there for 40 days he
attends an intensive outpatient program
3 days a week the school has um limited
his computer access a um
assistant in the classroom has to
monitor what he's
using and I did all I could as a parent
and I believe that this bill will help
with some of that
burden and hopefully will limit I
apologize that's your time limit if you
want to give you a sentence to two to
wrap up yeah um I think this bill should
be passed in order to help protect our
children not only from the short-term
effects of viewing obscene and
pornographic material but the long-term
effects that we know from studies exist
H I'm happy to take any questions
representative
McFarland thank you Mr chairman I think
all of us parents can understand the
concerns around uh both the the your
your children having access to these
kinds of materials as well as the ready
availability of Chromebooks and other
devices that are managed by others that
are thrust upon your children in in the
school systems
however I just want to understand it
seems that the bulk of your testimony is
as to the ineffectiveness of some of the
existing filtering mechanisms which are
being advocated for in this bill am I
misunderstanding as a parent knowing how
to turn on which ones and which ones to
turn off or what to wh list and what to
Blacklist on a computer is is an issue
my understanding of this bill is that
this filter is turned on and there is a
constant searching of the internet and
what the latest issues are because it
does
change thank you for your question
representative trip did you have a
question yes I do uh do you feel that
this uh bill should apply to uh the
computers that are found in the schools
yes and I believe it does because if I'm
understanding the bill correctly it says
anyone who disables this filter for a
minor will be charged
thank you for your question any other
questions seeing none thank you thank
you Patrick
hedger and MERS committee turn on your
mic I apologize uh thank you Mr chairman
and members of the committee my name is
Patrick hedger I am the director of
policy at net choice we are a trade
Association that represents and
advocates for free expression and free
enterprise online uh in line with that
mission we respectfully oppose HB 293
while certainly well- intended net
Choice opposes this bill primarily for
two reasons first it is unconstitutional
but if it were somehow enacted and
enforced the law is bad policy um it
would force all users to show ID to
access common websites such as Google
search without meaningfully inhibiting
access to obscene material HB 293 would
immediately face cons challenges similar
to those that struck down the
communications decency act in 1996 the
Supreme Court's unanimous decision in
Reno
vacu uh in the unlikely case that HB 293
survives scrutiny in the courts the risk
of unlimited private lawsuits at $50,000
each would force device manufacturers to
restrict access to internet browsers and
search burdening users of all ages uh
meaning everyone in this chamber would
essentially have to prove they were over
18 to use common internet browser and
search engines and I will add that in
the comparisons to the Utah law are not
perfect here because Utah's law no
longer contains the private right of
action um that uh would create these
potential lawsuits these unlimited
lawsuits and despite the severe
restrictions device manufacturers be
compelled to put in place the limited
scope of the fil required filter would
not meaningfully inhibit the ability of
adolescence to access obscene content
filter only applies to internet browsers
owned and controlled by the manual
ufacturer this does nothing to stop
obscene material through browsers apps
and search engines on the device that
are not affiliated with the device
manufacturer so for example users of
Safari on iPhone or Chrome on Android
would be burdened with showing ID to
access the web but adolescent ducko
users for example would still be access
able to access obscene material instead
of this legislation New Hampshire should
consider more targeted Solutions like
digital literacy education in schools or
better promotion of existing parental
control resources these approaches would
support families while preserving both
constitutional rights and Market
Innovation thank you for your time and
happy to take your questions thank you
any questions for this
witness seeing none thank you thank
you uh is it
Marissa fine f Marissa if you could hum
me with the last name I'm trying to read
it here fance fernance thank you I
and I was also
wonder he has a pink card yes Jason yes
thank
you
what we wouldn't share the time can we
combine our times together like four
minutes instead of two sure thank you
um all right so um thank you Mr chairman
me move that microphone closer to you
and thank you thank you Mr chairman and
members of the committee um you are
currently receiving a um paper that was
signed all these signatures were from
yesterday because I heard about this
bill last minute so we right there is
about 174 signatures from New Hampshire
parents and concerned citizens
who would love to see this bill pass and
this was all done yesterday after 4:00
so um also um my name is Marissa
Fernand I'm the national director of New
Hampshire traffic free Coalition and a
mother of three sons in the last six
years I have been focusing primarily on
the intersection of sex trafficking and
pornography AKA obscenity as well as how
online um obscenity affects children as
a result of this I have had um countless
other New Hampshire parents grandparents
as kind of like what everyone else is
saying come to me with heartbreaking
stories of how obscenity has um harmed
their children
um and I'm not going to get into as much
of mine because Jason is the technical
one so I'm going to let him go from here
but one thing I have continually do hear
from the parents um that I work with
that come to me with stories about their
children is they say this what is in
place is not enough they they cannot
keep up with the filters they don't know
how to put things in place and even
myself I should be an expert on this and
I can barely figure them out so on that
I hand it over to
Jason uh thank you for having me here uh
committee members uh I wanted to
introduce myself I'm Jason serson I'm a
resident of dun Barton I have six
children I published papers and patents
and cyber security I managed $100
million in research programs for the
Department of Defense at DARPA I've also
founded an AI and a cyber security firm
here in New Hampshire employing dozens
of Engineers I also testified as an
expert witness for the bill that passed
in Utah uh back in 2021 and they passed
a unanimous version in
2024 I'm here to testify that this bill
does not represent a technical or
unreasonable hardship for the
multi-billion I think now trillion
dollar companies involved like Amazon
Google and um uh Apple uh they already
have these device filters uh so uh I
believe representative McFarland made a
point about cars this doesn't apply to
cars it's specifically to mobile phones
and tablets so we're not trying to ban
uh pornography with the internet we're
not trying to prevent all forms of
lacious material from being access all
this bill is doing is saying let's not
have unrestricted access to the internet
on by default for children most people
uh you can talk to on the street or
probably on the committee would agree
you would not want unrestricted access
to the internet on by default this is
not saying parents are not responsible
for parenting it is saying that the 7 to
11 Step technical process currently
required by parents who often don't have
uh master's degrees in electric in
electrical engineering like I do may
have difficulty turning that on so
instead of forcing them to figure out
the 11 step process or even knowing such
a process exists and how to navigate
that that the device manufacturer who
already knows the age of the user
already has a filter on the device
simply turns on that filter I didn't
even know that they have it on by
default for 12y olds uh the goal is to
extend that up to still
teenagers uh so a couple of other
comments I wanted to make uh addressing
earlier points um the crime uh that was
mentioned earlier is only if someone
intentionally disables a filter to then
specifically to enable a minor to view
pornography not if it was just turned
off and it was accidentally viewed uh
the criminal component of the bill is if
someone is intentionally doing that to
bypass the filter and then a minor
actually does view pornography from that
device uh the other comment I want to
make about the awkward definition of
material and obscene material comes from
historical case law definitions the
important point of this bill is again
we're not uh addressing what is
pornography this has been litigated to
the Supreme Court the goal is to just
turn on the default filters that already
exists we're not getting into there's a
whole definition what is pornography
what is a filter it's only there to help
explain why the filter is there what the
filter is
doing uh so final comment uh we we heard
from the lobbying firm about why it's
unconstitutional uh the Myriad of
concerns of his testimony uh would
require an entire uh document to address
uh things like constitutionality are are
crazy this is not saying you can't
access the internet it's just saying for
children the filter that already exists
and is turned on and has no uh freedom
of speech issues should be turned on
instead of left off uh so there's
there's not an issue there things like
Duck Duck Go he mentioned uh would work
that's actually not true either uh there
are devices uh like Apple's filtering
acquire applies not just your time so if
you could just wrap up with a sentence
or two yep but to all devices on there
so yeah I just want to say if there are
any questions uh happy to speak now but
also afterward uh for the committee I
live not far from here and happy to uh
help however I can around the bill
representative Perez thanks for taking
um I know multiple people have gone to
multiple different school districts and
said hey my my 10-year-old 12y old
15-year-old are able to access anything
they want on the Chromebooks and they
the repeated answer that they're getting
back is well we can't we can't do
anything in your expertise is that true
can they really do something yeah so
that's a great question so I actually
work with the national on sexual
exploitation who has mentioned here
earlier uh as a board member uh because
my wife and I care about this topic so
deeply uh niosi has been lobbying and
has a dirty dozen list where they've
named Google among other companies as
facilitating sexual exploitation because
of their refusal historically to turn on
filtering by default two Chromebooks
sold to schools uh my understanding is
that that changed and now Chromebooks by
default are turning on filtering uh as
was mentioned earlier safe search I
believe representative Turner asked is
this the same as safe search it's not
the same as safe search at the device
level you can use uh the operating
system to filter content safe search is
specific to Google or or or a search
engine and it's saying filter at the
search engine level this is saying at
the device level Apple's device level
also can mandate safe search on the
browser so it does both uh if we do it
at the device level here so yes they can
be secured uh some schools turn off the
filtering because they or they don't
have it on by default historically uh
but there is a movement in a good
direction Google is starting to
recognize these concerns and and my
understanding is that they have started
to sell Chromebooks with filtering on by
default okay we haven't we don't have
time for that okay I mentioned that
earlier representative
tur yeah yeah thanks and and thank you
for um taking the question actually your
your last statement was a great segue to
my question which is we we heard earlier
that this is not safe search uh that
this is something more something that
involves AI um can you say a few words
about what we would be asking parents to
share with an AI um engine um in order
to utilize these functions regarding
their children's search and where would
that processing take
place great question uh this doesn't
have to do with parents sharing any
extra information or any AI or any data
mining it's purely when the device is
activated it asks for the age of the
user
ready that information is they'll last
for birthday things like that it's just
saying if the age is a minor then turn
on the filtering that's already on the
device just turn that on so there's not
a data mining component there's not AI
doing things you're correct there is AI
on some of the devices for identifying
what is pornographic or not but that's
separate the device manufacturer already
has that they use that to analyze
content and make decisions about whether
to filter or not uh this bill is purely
saying do you turn on the existing
filter technology that's already there
so it's an onoff switch and saying do
you turn on the filter that's there by
default representative
McFarlin thank you Mr chairman and and
thank you for your testimony Mr cyers uh
I my question for you and I just want to
clarify some comments you made you you
you indicated that uh you've read this
bill carefully um and where it describes
tablet as a mobile device equipped with
a mobile operating system system a
touchscreen display a rechargeable
battery and the ability to support
access to a cellular network and where
it defines smartphone to mean an
electronic device that combines a cell
phone with a handheld computer typically
offering internet access through a
browser or search engine data storage
text and email capabilities would you
agree that this bill would in fact not
cover Chromebooks in schools as one
example and would in fact cover uh
vehicles that meet the criteria in the
definition of
tablet it's a great question uh I would
agree it was not apply to Chromebooks as
Chromebooks would qualify as a laptop
computer and this does not apply to
laptop computers uh I don't think in my
technical uh interpretation that a
mobile device with a mobile operating
system would be uh confused with a car
um but I do understand that argument
because some people do actually take
tablets and like inject them into the C
dashboard of an autom motive so I could
see how one would interpret it that way
and if it was me I might recommend
modifying some of the language there to
remove that ambiguity but I I do think
most interpretations of this if someone
says tablet they don't think you're Ford
Explorer um but I do understand why
someone might have that concern thank
you representative mayos thank you Mr
chair and thank you Mr serson for taking
my question I'm wondering if you would
agree that the manufacturing implicates
interstate commerce and if that's true
whether this would be better H um
handled at the federal level rather than
at the state level thank you yeah thank
thank you for that question it's a great
question uh there are many things that
are done uh at the interstate level I
think most of the products we import
here in New Hampshire come from out of
state um that does not mean uh we
neglect our uh responsibility to
legislate uh safety devices I think
California has made a living in in
telling the world's many ufacturers how
they need to manufacture things uh in
this case we already have the state of
Utah doing this and I think n's strategy
for this legislation is to have it pass
at the state level show that there's a
movement and support across uh the
Republic and and demonstrate that uh
while moving towards eventual Federal
legislation uh because I think this is a
common sense bill that most people again
if you talk to people on the street
they're shocked that this is not already
a thing or why that's an issue you any
other questions of this Witness
seeing none thank
you Juan
Bono thank you chair and committee
members for the opportunity to testify
my name is ju Lono I'm speaking on
behalf of the taxpayers protection
Alliance or TPA a nonprofit nonpartisan
taxpayer advocacy consumer watch
organization respectfully TPA opposes
this bill devis filter bills or like HB
293 is well intentioned for sure but
they have glaring constitutional issues
preventing miners from accessing obscene
content is a Lal goal but as been has
been said before it's precisely the
creation of this obscene content
category which ultimately become the
Bill's shortfall by creating a category
of content that is considered obscene
which platforms are now going to be
required to block off for minors the
government will then become the
arbitrate of what speech is considered
obscene or not designating a government
with the task of determining what type
of speech and by quoting the bill lack
serious literary artistic political or
scientific value as theine of the bill
will present a clear cut of front of the
the First Amendment these constitutional
issues will inevitably get the state of
New Hampshire involving costly lawsuits
to defend the constitutionality of the
bill with taxpayers are going to
ultimately F foot in the bill existing
precedents such as renew renew versus
ACLU or Brown versus the entertainment
Merchants associating and the plethora
of state level rulings indicate that
taxpayers are going to be paying for a
losing case children Educators and
parents already have a vast array of
parental control tools at the disposal
that prevent children from accessing
inappropriate content these controls can
not only be found in the devices
themselves but also on the online
platforms or with their internet service
providers legisl legislative efforts
should be focusing on helping parents
and Guardians be aware of these tools
and see how they can effectively use
them as a taxpayer advocacy organization
in the name of taxpayers and fiscal
responsibility in New Hampshire TP TPA
encourages to reject this Bill thank you
so much thank you any questions of this
witness representative
McFarland thank you Mr chairman and uh
and thank you for your
testimony as I have heard all the
testimony in in support or opposition to
this bill one of the things that I think
we haven't spoken to is as to the
opportunity for children to be able to
compute and hack on their devices in
ways that are highly educational and
that may have contributed to the
qualifications of of some of our
previous Witnesses in your understanding
does this bill uh end up creating a
circumstance where we are
disenfranchising our children
uh it's it's a very good question I
think as you mentioned the problematic
part of the bill in that case if is a
children Tinkers with the device as you
mentioned is hacker and trying to open
up the the OS and deactivates this
filter I get I think it opens
opportunity for this kid to be
considered a Fallon under definition uh
of the Bill thank you any other
questions seeing none thank
you I don't have any more pink cards is
anyone else that wish is to speak on
this bill it hasn't filled out a pain
card seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing on House Bill
293 and just mention that it's afternoon
if somebody wants to go ahead and take a
break corkin is been waiting patiently
I'm GNA have his bill next I just want
to make sure that if you want to take a
break we're going to run through here
but if you need to go get something to
eat or whatever please go ahead and do
that on your
own okay should I'm not going to open
the hearing on house Bill 253 and
represent uh and and recognize
representative corkrin to introduce the
Bill thank you so uh after some of the
monster bills you had this morning uh
hopefully this will be five minutes of
testimony by me and no one else and you
can all get
lunch so all of the lawyers on the
committee uh probably know exactly what
iala is uh but for those of us who are
not lawyers I'll take just 30 seconds to
explain it whenever one of us uses an
attorney for various things whether a
inheritance is being dealt with or
there's uh some funds from the
transaction selling real estate or um
the results of a lawsuit have come in
and are being held by the attorney until
they're dispersed you know 30 days or 90
days later that money is put in a
savings account that is under the
control of the uh attorney for the
benefit of the uh recipient and uh the
attorney is not going to spin up you
know 150 different savings accounts for
each of his 150 clients during the year
he will just have one savings account um
pile all the money in and disperse it as
uh the dispersals are required um and
that's quite
reasonable uh and the attorney himself
is keeping track of how much needs to be
dispersed to each entity so um you know
if I have $1,000 for my benefit that
lands in an attorney's uh trust account
uh and it comes out 30 days later it
might have earned you know $6 in
interest or whatever the math is and
simultaneously other amounts are landing
in there and also generating interest
from the bank um at the end of the year
it would be wildly impractical for an
attorney to go through and say uh Travis
corkran had $600 for 91 days at
1.2% we need to mail him a check for a16
and so forth and so on so the um
way that this is resolved and and yet
that money also shouldn't flow to the
attorney he hasn't earned that interest
uh the way that this is resolved is
currently by New Hampshire bar rules
using a program called IA which uh
stands for uh interest bearing accounts
or you know interest on trusty accounts
um this is all fairly reasonable um but
the question is exactly who disperses
these funds and what criteria do they
use and if we've been following the news
recently with the revelations about the
us uh government's budget and the US Aid
uh money which has effectively uh been
this vast dark slush fund that has been
dispersed to all sorts of entities and
uh dispersed not in a sort of an
even-handed way where we're you know
just paying for you know first aid in
this place and you know libraries over
there but a lot of it has been very very
very targeted um and you know this is
the federal level and I'm making an
analogy so just you know 10 more seconds
I'll get back to New Hampshire but it
has been targeted by those who are aware
of how these uh non-governmental
organization mechanisms work and it is
directed to uh Allied uh Nos and uh used
for very very political purposes often
so the iala fund in New Hampshire is uh
effectively a tax on New Hampshire
citizens those who use attorneys um for
sort of any purpose and uh this money is
being dispersed uh the this tax dollars
in a sense uh metaphorically so is being
dispersed not by representatives of the
citizens but by members of the bar
association and uh I found several
different numbers talking about the
total amount um some numbers say half a
million some say about a million a year
some say two million a year um but
reviewing the grants that have been
given um some of these grants are fairly
neutral and sound like good ideas you
know organization to help the indent or
whatever um some of them uh on the other
hand are very much on one side of the
political aisle uh going to
organizations that are involved in
lobbying or helping uh very particular
groups and um I pulled up just a few
examples and I don't want to go through
the entire spreadsheet um but grants are
going to New Hampshire Catholic
Charities uh which uses them for among
other purposes to help settle refugees
in New Hampshire um that goes to the
Manchester chapter of the
NAACP and while that organization may do
some good uh things it has also done
other things uh such as endorsing or
pushing for laws that infringe on the
first amendment by criminalizing the
display of the Confederate flag and to
um pushing for uh laws against quote
unquote disinformation and for pushing
uh for laws that would criminalize
Behavior by private firms um as uh
racist or discriminatory not based on
any evidence of that by just by
disperate impact um let's see there's
also the disabilities Right Center has
been a uh
uh receiver of these funds and one of
the things that they do is launch
lawsuits against private firms uh if in
the view of the disability rights Center
they have you know the handicapped door
was blocked for you know 15 minutes or
the sort of thing so um you know I need
not say that every single recipient of
these funds uh is necessarily doing bad
or doing bad all of the time but we do
have this situation where there are sort
of dark funds that are being taken from
citizens as a whole and directed very
much in one side of the political aisle
uh this bill um gets back to the
original idea behind IA funds which is
there is in fact a huge transaction cost
to tracking every single penny um and
that would not be realistic to mail out
thousands of checks for 60 cents each um
and it specifies
that let's see just one
second the uh funds instead flow to New
Hampshire's public defenders
and this is I think a uh idea that
should be palatable to people on both
sides of the aisle um you know the
libertarian could see you know what is
it that public defenders do they help
individual citizens who are often very
much mismatched in a David and Goliath
situation against prosecutors with
effectively unlimited budgets and on the
left side of the aisle you could see you
know effectively the same um that you
know the these are not handouts to
billionaires or you know gun
manufacturers manufacturers or anything
um but again supporting a very uh
pro-social um good uh
program I'm happy to answer any
questions representative uh
Horgan I guess you actually just to
jumped out of me looking at build lines
14 like trying to prevent um prevent
them from contributing any funds to any
nonprofit organization and you explained
why that is and you cited three examples
which you
think are bad although I'm not sure if
everybody in the room would agree
especially Disability Rights Association
I'm not sure if you actually
characterized what they do but I think
they're an excellent organization I'm
member of at least one that's been cited
by your co-sponsor as an NGO
um I'm just ask would would it be would
it be uh would you be would it be would
you consider a friendly Amendment if we
simply said they had to disclose uh what
other organizations are donating to have
a blanket prohibition on it um because I
think and what would they do if the
vendor office just um continued donating
to organizations which at least maybe
you find objectionable um what if they
simply what would be the consequences if
they simply refuse to take the funds and
um decide to seek their funds elsewhere
rather than have this restriction on
their activities so um I believe that uh
if they refuse to take the funds uh
those would be swept to the general fund
um
I I certainly remember that uh back and
forth uh talking to the uh OS um and my
eyes are a little blurry right now uh
and so my uh answer is that no I would
not um you know obviously it's not my
decision um but I would not recommend an
amendment of that form because that
allows for basically uh the exact
current situation to take place where uh
you know people in a small community who
work together say hey you know it was
very much Our intention to fund this one
activist group but now we can't do it
directly it goes to you guys would you
mind making sure that it still flows to
them um I think that it is reasonable
for the uh House of Representatives to
identify the public defender office as a
worthy cause and to specify that the
funds should go there and should stay
there for the benefit of their
clients followup I guess you're saying
the defender office you wouldn't give
them the uh you would deny them the the
right to support other organizations
which they feel uh are they feel like
help them achieve their their partner
for other organizations which help them
achieve their mission so you would like
deny them the right just because some
third party may not necessarily agree
with who they who they choose it would
not deny them that right they have
absolutely every right to do that but if
they choose to do that they would be
choosing between two Alternatives and
one of them would be this additional
source of funding for their core
Mission any other question questions
representative Alexander thank you Mr
chair thank you representative um how
much money are we talking about um I've
seen various conflicting numbers I
believe it's about $2 million a
year any other questions representative
McFarland thank you Mr chairman uh
representative Corran if we were to
contemplate an amendment as was being
discussed a few moments ago and provide
uh the these lawyers with the
opportunity to to seek to direct the
funds elsewhere would that in your
opinion increase the costs of
administration and audit of this statute
um I I think that's quite likely we
would have to um you know review where
it was going and see if these you know
were activist NOS or something else uh
and and again I I think that the purpose
of an amendment um you know I I
shouldn't say purpose it's always sort
of a rhetorical fallacy to attribute
that um but I think that that sort of
you know patches one hole in the boat
and then just immediately opens up
another one saying you can't uh send
funds to you know NOS except you can
route it through this office and then
they can send funds to NOS so I do not
see it as being a a great approach thank
you representative okay representative
Smith thank you very much um do you
recognize any difference between funding
um uh entities which provide uh criminal
representation versus civil case
representation um it's my understanding
that the public defender office only
provides criminal defense uh I I could
be incorrect on that and if I am I'll
I'll uh acknowledge that correction
could I follow up
yes yes thank you um actually that is my
understanding um also and it and it is
also my understanding that the public
defender can go to the fiscal committee
and in fact does go to the fiscal
committee regularly when there is Need
for additional funding for um criminal
defense um do you then think that civil
defense is not as um important in our
justice system as criminal defense um I
I think that it is definitely important
I I guess if you're explicitly asking me
to rank order is it less important I
would say it is less important um you
know I have uh LED sort of an
interesting life and I've been on uh
both sides of multiple lawsuits and um
being involved in a civil lawsuit is
exciting uh being a defendant against
the government when they're attempting
to press criminal charges is much more
exciting um so I think that the public
defenders office does great work uh
helping people who cannot afford their
own defense and and this again gets to
uh sort of the David and Goliath problem
where you could have somebody you know
not graduating the top half of his of
his high school class not having family
resources and you know through a mistake
or you know even an intentional error um
you know is you know was in the wrong
car with the wrong friend and suddenly
there's you know accessory to this and
felony weight of that and this other
thing uh and there are people who end up
facing sort of you know huge uh
precarious situations and so the public
defender gives these people um you know
some help in that situation so if I
could you know uh rank order you know
should the public defender office or any
group either help someone who's looking
at 20 years to life or help someone
who's looking at a $50,000 civil
judgment uh I would certainly think that
the former is a much higher priority U
thank you although I'd like to follow up
I'm afraid that the um the sponsors
answers might be so long that we ought
to try to I I can try to be briefer okay
that's all right okay thank you
representative mayos thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my question um I
wanted to ask um the bill says that the
public defenders office would lose their
funding from myala if they contributed
any funds to any nonprofit organization
so do you contemplate that for example
if the public defenders were a sponsor
at the bar association midyear or end
year meeting and they made a
contribution and were a sponsor or that
if they paid a nonprofit organization to
train new upand cominging public
defender attorneys that then they would
lose their iila funding that is a very
well crafted sort of adversarial
question that gets to the worst possible
aspect of this and I'd say Yes um uh it
absolutely would and um you know on on
the one hand you could say well you know
there there should be you know carats
for this and that and uh I abs
understand the utility of those sorts of
things and how that is in keeping with
the core mission of the public defender
office um but the problem is that uh you
could either have a very simple rule
saying no pass through donations to
other NOS or you could uh you know
getting this very complicated subjective
standard where you know uh not you know
directly contributing to the core
Mission and then we have a conversation
about you know is the public defender
office passing money to some activist
group that is seeking to influence
legislation which some people approve of
and other citizens disapprove of um you
know relevant and again getting back to
the federal example with us Aid once you
open the door to could it plausibly be
construed as in the interest of you know
etc etc etc then pretty soon you uh you
know have have no barriers whatso
whatsoever to funding insane things
which is the problem that I'm trying to
address any other questions of this
witness seeing none thank you thank you
for your time
Michael from the public defendant office
and I can't really read the last time I
apologize thank
you turn the mic yeah yep there you go
my name is Michael a capino and I
currently have the privilege of serving
as the chairman of the board of
directors of New Hampshire public
defender um New Hampshire public
defender does not take a position on
this bill but I am here to provide
information to you all about um the
program uh first of all we were not
consulted about this bill uh nobody um
got in touch with the public defender to
uh determine uh exactly what we do or
How We Do It um secondly I want to make
it clear that the New Hampshire public
defender does not make contributions to
political
campaigns and we do not make
contributions to other uh nonprofit
organizations or
oros there are times where we may need
services from other NOS for instance if
we need a particular language
interpreter um we may hire that person
from a service such as a Lutheran
Services organization or something like
that but we consider that to be payment
for services and not a contribution to
such an
organization
um so I just want to get that out on the
table first of all because this bill
seems to suggest uh that we would need
some kind of oversight um with respect
to I guess NOS is the word uh that is
concerning um I also want to explain to
you a little bit about what New
Hampshire public defender is we are not
a state agency we are a private
Corporation uh by Statute we provide we
are the agency that has chosen to
provide uh Indigent criminal defense
services to the state of New Hampshire
we do that through an arrangement with
the judicial Council uh our budget um is
uh our contract I should say um comes
from the budget of the judicial Council
um for the last bium it was $28 million
per year we
have3 30 plus or minus lawyers working
for us right now and 10 offices
throughout uh the state of New Hampshire
um our
um the way that it works is we contract
with the judicial Council the judicial
Council seeks a budget from uh the
governor and then ultimately from the
house we have in fact received um money
um when the budget uh when the contract
didn't cover it as representative Smith
has has indicated we have gone to um to
house uh to the financial uh committee
on occasion when uh we needed
um to uh Shore up the budget for one
reason or another um but our our uh
money comes through a contract with the
state um so I just wanted to point that
out and the other thing is we don't do
any civil representation we represent
individuals in the state courts before
the New Hampshire parole board um and uh
occasionally we will provide advice and
counsel when one of our clients is
called before some board where their
Fifth Amendment right to remain silent
may be in may be uh involved um but uh
the judicial Council also provides uh
the budget line for Casa for New
Hampshire legal assistance and for
assigned councils and for uh contract
Council so we we are part of a much
bigger um
appropriation um so I'm happy to answer
any any questions that anybody has I do
appreciate the prior speakers um latory
remarks about our program I do believe
that we uh have an excellent public
defender program here in the state of
New Hampshire I believe that our lawyers
every day are out there uh uh pursuing
our major cause which is to provide the
best sixth amendment protection to the
citizens of New Hampshire that is
available any questions representative
McFarland thank you Mr chairman uh is it
your position that the public defenders
office is fully funded or do you believe
that you could benefit from these
additional funds depends what you mean
by fully funded um we we I I don't think
it's any secret and by the way our
budget as being part of the um judicial
Council
uh there is a reference in this bill to
um we have to publish our our budget to
to get the money um it's part it's
already public it's part of what uh the
judicial Council puts out each year um
so but um are we fully funded no and I
don't think that we have enough lawyers
right now um I think in fact if you read
the New Hampshire bar news there's a
recent um there's a recent uh article in
that uh publication uh laying out how um
our current staff is uh overburdened we
have very high case loads right now um
we uh sought a a bunch more money than
is in the current um judicial Council uh
appropriation um or I should say request
at this point for the upcoming bium um
so um but we are laboring to fix that
problem uh we uh have an attrition
problem with lawyers uh that leave and
and it's very difficult to hire new
lawyers these days um so I would I would
say we're fully funded for what we have
but New Hampshire needs a larger public
defender program with public defenders
who have lower case
loads Representative
mayos no any other
questions seeing none thank you thank
you Kathy Fox
well good afternoon I'll be brief I
don't want to stand between you and
lunch but you have a written testimony I
am Kathy Cory Fox for the record and I'm
here on behalf for the N Hampshire bar
assoc the N Hampshire bar Foundation um
chairman Scott Harris of the bar
Foundation his testimony just to
highlight a couple of things in his uh
letter to you uh the first paragraph
highlights the how the I olter fund has
come about through the New Hampshire
Supreme Court their
rules um the New Hampshire bar
Foundation is a nonprofit public charity
it's made up of 19
volunteers but I'd like to bring to your
attention the last p paragraph that
you'll see that during the last fiscal
year the Iota grants provided legal
assistance for
14,28 to individuals in our
state it improves the life the the um
access to Justice administration of
justice but it also
works directly with legal aid
organizations that provide uh
representation such as in the family
court so it's an important aspect in the
uh judicial system and on behalf of the
New Hampshire bar Foundation we
respectfully ask that you vote
inexpedient to legislate on this bill
I'm happy to take any questions and I
thank you for your time are there any
questions representative
Horan so my um it looks like so
basically what what you and Attorney
Harris are saying who whose letter
you're passing around is basically this
this bill is unnecessary because a
similar program has already been
um been created by the bar foundation
and mean I suppose you have the and so
there's really no need to uh replace
that with this government run program
that's envisioned in the
bill I I I think the concern is to have
a disruption in what is already in
practice that that answer your question
sir so the buyer Foundation has already
set something like this up and and I
guess it is voluntary if a lawyer wants
to send out a check for dollar six to
their client here she's free to do so
but they this is obviously more
efficient okay representative
Smith representative Alexander thank you
Mr chair thank you for answering my
question of course um
I kind of what I what I saw was like in
third paragraph at the last sentence
it's unclear if this incentive would be
available if Iola funds were diverted to
other
purposes is there like not a better
purpose than Shoring up the you know
underfunded public defenders office I
guess I'm wondering like you like you
believe that Banks
would reduce the interest rates that
they're offering for for these
um these funds if the funds were
diverted to the public defenders office
you know that's a very good question and
I and let me get back to you on that
that is a very good question on that
there question just just to follow up I
mean I don't I don't see the nefarious
public defenders office as being
something where the banks would be like
oh okay like we can't offer these
payments anymore right thank you for the
question any other questions
representative Smith um do you see um IA
funds um as a uh as a tax which is what
the sponsor alluded
to thank you for the question um
personally I don't
ma would could would there be any
possible reason to see this as a
tax it frankly representative thank you
I've never looked at it that way um in
that sense there thank you you're
welcome any other questions
representative Manos thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking my question um
in the last paragraph um the iila
funding that goes to the agencies that
are funded and then Pro provide legal
representation to Indigent clients that
actually helps the court system does it
not by assisting people who would
otherwise be prosay in within the um
civil side of the legal system thank you
for the question representative I would
agree uh several of you uh last session
sat on the special Committee of the
family court one thing that resonated
with me was that say lians and family
court with
80% any other
questions seeing none thank you thank
you Mr chair Reverend Dr Gail
Kenny for
so Mr chair and members of the committee
for the record um my name is Gail Kenny
I am a clergy person with the United
Church of Christ and I am a resident of
Kanan New Hampshire but in another life
um I worked for the New Hampshire Bar
Association and I was present when the
Ia program in New Hampshire was created
and um my job at the time with the bar
association was to to oversee and ensure
the implementation of the Iola program
and to oversee how the money was was
spent and where it went so I am
intimately familiar with the Iola
program its purpose and its
implementation and its use even though I
have been away from it for a number of
years at this point um this
I think it's I would implore this
committee before um voting on this bill
to have a clear understanding of what
the program is and what the bill is
trying to do and what the implications
of this bill is and I will say that my
listening to the sponsor was the sponsor
did not have a clear understanding of
the program and purposes and from whence
it came um uh let's just start off I
will I want to address a representative
Smith's
question the money that is created
through the Iola program absent the
Supreme Court rule in 1982 to create it
um the money would not
exist what um when lawyers in private
practice hold funds for that are very
minimal in amount or for a short period
of time for example real estate closing
where they might get a certain amount of
money one day they turn it over the next
day it stays in the bank only overnight
um over the decades it had been
recognized that small amounts of money
held by attorneys or money held for a
short period of time would not generate
enough interest in order to make it U
financially feasible and beneficial to
the client for that money to be um put
into a separate account for the benefit
of the client so the client could earn
interest for example they could earn $5
of interest and yet for the cost to um
that would be built to the client for
creating the account monitoring the
account closing the account and then
turning the money back over to the
client far far far would exceed the
amount of interest that was created so
over the years lawyers put that money in
noninterest bearing accounts that's
where that shortterm a small amount of
money always existed no money was
created but the I ala rule from the
Supreme Court said it's okay for
attorneys to pull those small amounts or
short-term amounts into a single
interest bearing account as long as the
interest goes
solely for civil legal services for the
Civil legal services for the poor or
other public information about the law
and the legal system so it is creating
money that would not exist it is not a
tax on
anybody it is not money that that the
government had to begin with the
government had a say over it's money
that otherwise would not exist without
that Supreme Court rule so
this built and to me creates two
significant concerns the first one is
jurisdictional the Iola program oh first
the New Hampshire Supreme Court has
Regulatory and supervisory authority
over the legal profession in New
Hampshire and as part of exercising its
Regulatory and supervisory Authority it
set up rule um through rule 50 of the
Supreme Court and uh the rule 50 I
attached to my testimony so that
everybody can see it
created uh the Iola program the second
state in the nation to create it the
first was Florida then the Florida
Supreme Court chief justice um visited
New Hampshire to explain the program to
New Hampshire and the Supreme Court
after much um a thorough research of
what the implications were um created
the rule in 1982 um to um create the
program so the bill 253 says in essence
is saying that um it is going to just
absolutely ignore the Supreme Court rule
and the Supreme Court um regulatory
authority over the bar and and to say
that the Supreme Court no longer has any
authority to direct where this money
should go the jurisdictional question is
what is in the legislative purview what
is in the executive purview what is in
the Court's purview three co-equal
branches of government this bill usurps
and ignores and sets a precedent that
the legislature seizes for itself
regulatory authority over the Supreme
Court you really need to think long and
hard about whether or not this is
something that the legislature should be
weighing into and doing um the second
thing is
moral paying for criminal
legal services for the poor for Indigent
defense the public defender program is a
constitutional requirement through the
sixth and the 14th amend amendment is
constitutionally required for the state
to pay for Indigent criminal defense as
provided um by the public defender
program and then some other um attorneys
it is a state responsibility the state
has zero responsibility to provide civil
Le services for the poor and yet access
to Justice will not happen in the state
of New Hampshire unless people in Civil
Court have access to attorneys to to
legal
representation that's what the iila
program does uh provides that and so if
this bill were to pass and you take away
all that money $1 to2 million a year
providing civil legal services to the
poorest people in the state of New
Hampshire um morally what are you going
to replace that with you're just taking
it away completely so now the the poor
in New Hampshire that are trying to you
know um tenants with um with evictions
or people in abuse cases that
desperately need legal services are no
longer going to have that funding
because this bill has taken it away
there's a moral responsibility of of
this committee and the legislature
determine what happens to all those
people if this bill were to pass
jurisdictional moral I implore you to
find this inexpedient to legislate that
it's not understood by the sponsors and
it is just it would be a travesty to to
weigh into this representative Alexander
thank you Mr chair thank you I'm right
here thank you for taking my question
and um your testimony was really
valuable to understand this a little
better um I understand your
jurisdictional question but the moral
one I'm kind of hung up about because
wouldn't you agree that criminal cases
and the government's um like the
legislator's responsibility to fund
under the under the Constitution would
be more of a of a moral obligation than
funding civil cases I guess I guess I'm
I guess I'm confused with the the
stretch I think you're stretching it a
little bit
I don't think you pit one against the
other first of all I I would you
prioritize them right I'm just asking no
access to justice is access to Justice
whether you're in criminal court or
whether you're in Civil Court morally
the entire population when they come up
against things which are legal in
concept and for which representation
would make a difference in their lives
there is no difference the difference
between um Justice for criminal
defendants and justice for people in
civil court access to justice is access
to Justice period the difference is and
the only difference is it is a
constitutional
requirement for um people to have um
access to defense in Criminal Court
there's no constitutional requirement in
regards to civil court
representative McFarland thank you Mr
chairman and thank you to the Reverend
Kenny for your persuasive testimony and
it's it's a pleasure to see one of my
constituents here I I just want to ask
you know I I think that representative
Alexander raises some valid
concerns um around what the the sort of
the moral uh what the greater moral
issue is what the moral equivalence is
uh of where these funds are directed but
even if
you say okay we we we should be fully
fun funding the public defender office
uh from the state budget and we should
be focusing here on civil Legal Services
if you're sympathetic to the sponsors
concerns that some of these civil legal
organizations uh have a partisan nature
to them can you represent or recommend
uh your point of view around what civil
Legal Services organizations exist that
steer away from partisanship
I'm
not totally fully I I I think I
understand what you're saying I'm not
fully ask more
simply if if we were to say instead of
saying we're going to redirect These
funds to the public defender if we were
to say we're going to redirect them to
an organization that's focused on civil
Legal Services what should that
organization
be there are multiple organizations in
New Hampshire that provide um civil
legal services to to the poor um and I
don't have the current list of of who is
getting um Ulta money
um however I will tell you that in 1982
the Supreme Court very very very
carefully studied what the implications
would be and where this money would go
and since that time through the New
Hampshire bar Association which is
directed by the Supreme Court to oversee
the Iola program they too look very
carefully at where the money is going
what is being used for it is not being
used for political purposes it is not
being used for lobbying purposes it is
used for the purpose of helping
individuals have their day in court in
civil cases with the representation they
need in order to achieve Justice it is
so carefully controlled and overse
seeing that that um
it's well I'm sorry not go on but
it's concerns what you're hinting at
have been addressed and they are
concerns shared by the Supreme Court and
if the Supreme Court quite frankly in
its regulatory wisdom had any hint or
any feeling that there were issues they
would take a look at their Rule and
their regulation and their oversight
authority over this program and Over the
Bar and would make any changes necessary
thank you very much are there any other
questions seeing none thank
you Ain
krian good afternoon members of the
committee I'm Aaron krian general
counsel for the court system
um wanted to uh come up and discuss this
with you if you had any questions about
um the role of the courts with Iola it
is currently Supreme Court rule 50 that
lays out how IA funds are collected and
it turns them over to the bar to
disperse I think as you hear up to about
$2 million which goes I believe
predominantly to civil legal aid
organizations um when folks come to the
courts and it's not a criminal matter
they're not seeking criminal
representation it is very common that
they ask us how do I get a lawyer I or I
can't afford one what do I do um we are
often referring them letting them know
that these civil a organizations exist
um it is something that I hear very
frequently from legislators that they
have concern about how large the
self-represented population in New
Hampshire is um and I think you also see
a kind of legislative drift over time to
increase the number of subjects that
there is mandatory statutory
representation for not constitutional
like criminal but mandatory statutory
that was just increased again um for
children in residential proceedings last
year by the by the legislature to
increase mandatory representation by
attorneys so I I hear your concern about
people being represented I hear your
concern about funding the public
defender program and making sure that
people have lawyers in other contexts
because I think you do hear from your
constituents that they are very scared
to go to court sometimes um even in
situations where they don't have a a
constitutional right to a lawyer or
where they don't have a statutory right
to a lawyer um so I hear the the the
concerns on on both sides for this issue
um one thing I might suggest is that um
you know folks may not know that it is
actually uh a democratic process to be
involved with the Supreme Court's rules
under the very next rule uh rule 51 any
person in the state of New Hampshire
member of the public a lawyer can
propose a change to as a Supreme Court
rule or any Court rule um I think this
is completely underutilized and I think
we'd love to hear from folks more more
about whether they would want to change
these rules or whether they feel that
they're working but um one thing I might
just put to your consideration and this
just one thing to think is it could be
confusing to have a a legislative
provision that says one thing and a
Supreme Court rule it says another um it
it might be something better to work
together on and invite anyone who's
interested to come and perhaps pitch a
change to that rule through the rule 51
process which really is just sending an
email and if you have any trouble with
it feel free to reach out to me and I'm
happy to help so that we can kind of
bring all the different thoughts on IA
into one process um you know
representative Lynn when he's not in
Vietnam or somewhere uh sits on that
committee I think other legislators do
as well so it's something that we we
welcome legislative interaction with as
well representative Alexander thank you
thank you Miss kran for being here is it
I I I guess I maybe I'm a new legislator
and I what's the process for getting an
opinion from the court relative to if
fulta fund should be used
for criminal Legal Services as well
great question I think typically I
wouldn't try to give you a policy
opinion um you know we we do try to be
restrained in in in making a suggestion
to on policy should you have new
statutory civil representation rights
should you you know fund one
organization or another I I wouldn't
want to give advice on that because I
know that's a role that the legislature
is very predominant in um so that's
that's a tough one for me to answer if
you're asking about legal questions
there is a process in our constitution
for the legislature to send a legal
question over to the justices of the
Supreme Court another thing that I think
was great to use whenever you have a
question as a body that you would like
to refer to them as a legal matter but
really participation in this process is
open it's it's about making a suggestion
through rule 51 and then it's it's
debated with the people who participate
in rules as well as any member of the
public who wants to participate
representative McFarland thank you Mr
chairman listening to the the previous
testimony uh do you have a point of view
as to the governance that exists uh in
furtherance of the Supreme Court rule 50
and whether or not there may be an issue
to address with regard to the specific
nature of the organizations that those
funds are currently being distributed to
and and the actions that they're taking
with them to to give only factual
information that I hold I I would hate
to not know something that would be
important to you I I believe that these
organizations are 501c3 so they're not
donating to political parties or persons
or campaigns they may for example come
to the legislature and speak to you
about the concerns and the things that
they observe in the course of doing that
work um so I I I don't say that to say
that they're a person could not have a
concern that they would want to bring
forward to discuss more I'm certainly
happy to hear that but I I think there
are legal bars to the extent of the
different activities that that these
organizations
take thank you any other
questions yes representative Smith just
following up let me just use an example
of an organization that I'm quite
familiar with um the disabilities rights
Center um isn't it
possible that some member of the
legislature might believe that people
with
disabilities should not not be
entitled to certain civil
protections and uh whereas the whole
purpose of the DRC
funded as as it is um does believe that
that people with disabilities should be
entitled and is it possible then that A
legislature might see that decision as
political rather than constitutional
statutory
and
legitimate I believe you have given me a
rhetorical question representative Smith
of course I have and and I I I I think
that um with within uh the court system
you are famous for your excellent
questions and I I thank you for them
they're very good questions uh you know
legislators they have different views on
what's important and what they want to
bring forward as as a part of the public
concern and I would never want to
discourage any legislator from bringing
forward a concern that they have it's
very frequent in the court system when
we do get comments on our rules that we
hear that people think that they are not
working and they want to change them and
they're changed every year the rules are
changed every year in response to
people's concerns so if someone has a
concern they want to bring forward I'm
not trying to discourage them but yes
people can disagree about the meaning of
a word like political which may mean
different things to different people in
different context I will tell you as
someone who also serves as the Ada
coordinator for the judicial branch um
questions for Ada representation are
common and I am I am commonly referring
people because we cannot be their lawyer
and be their court system I am commonly
telling them here somewhere you can go
if you need someone to be your lawyer
not help you with your accommodations
process as a neutral government official
but advocate for you um here's here's a
place that you can go to get those
Services thank you representative Horgan
um thank you very much this most may be
somewhat rhetorical question too but
like there was an example given the
prime sponsor was objecting to the
disability rights Center because I'm not
sure what the story was exactly but
apparently they had sued somebody
because the handicap door had been
blocked for some period of time that he
felt was too short to be problem with
but first of all do you do you know from
your experience of a lawyer with the
just ran so first of all one party's
view of a situation may something may
seem trivial to one side of the dispute
may like Loom large for other people and
also it's a related thing off don't
people often sometimes bring complaints
based on one incident but that's it's
motivated because there's a larger
pattern of conduct which they find uh
they find objectional and that could
certainly and that probably turns up a
lot in U you know Ada type cases like
what the DRC deals with and and I
wouldn't um I wouldn't say that I have a
very good knowledge of all of the types
of suits that uh disability rights
Center brings I certainly think it's
accurate that they are assisting people
to sue in situations in which disability
right may have been violated that's I
think that's exactly this the purpose of
the organization but what I would want
to say is if if folks have concerns
about the transparency or about the
distribution of these funds I'm not
trying to discourage them I think you
know we we want to have the
participation of the bar and the public
in the work of the courts and so I it's
not something where I'd say don't bring
that forward I'd say let's bring it all
maybe into one track and and have that
conversation representative Alexander
just real quick I think um what would be
valuable for the committee is if um the
funding and where it goes is sent to the
committee like uh I think that it's
available to get it's publicly available
if I I think if you can help us track
that down that'd be
great any other
questions seeing none thank
you I do not have any more pink cards
for House Bill 253 is there anyone that
wishes to speak on it that hasn't filled
out a card
yet seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing on House Bill
253 and I'm going to open up the hearing
on House Bill 391 and recognize the
prime sponsor representative uh
Corrin take take a few minutes
okay I'll be back
remember this
representative corkran if you could fill
out a pink card at ear's convenience too
that'd be
great
welcome thank
you thank you um so
uh there is a phrase that you know um
when an idea you know nothing can stand
against an idea when it's time has
and so I keep bringing this uh Bill back
year after year and one of these years
we'll find out that its time has come so
um I muster a lot of uh support last
year sadly the various attorneys who
backed me up last time weren't able to
make it this time but to recap the
argument slap slap stands for strategic
lawsuit against public
participation um and the term sort of
explains itself which is you know a lot
of lawsuits are for very good intentions
you are suing for ex exactly the thing
you want there's been a zoning violation
you're suing to remedy that there's been
a civil rights violation you're suing to
remedy that but it is possible to use a
lawsuit Not For What on its face it is
doing uh but for its side effects and we
have heard this called colloquially
lawfare um lawfare is when you sort of
uh you know one party has Bigger Pockets
um and sues another party basically just
so that the process can be the
punishment
and not only does this hurt the uh
initial uh questions I'm on the right
bill right yes okay yeah I'm just listen
okay great there was just a look and uh
it's been a bit of a day so I I didn't
want to give a whole bunch of slap
testimony for a open government data
initiative
um so uh you know especially when one
party has much deeper Pockets than the
other they can not only um make it
absolutely untenable for a small party
via a lawsuit um but you know of uh I
can't speak French but you know poorly
encouragement of the others or whatever
um to make it very clear that if you go
up against this much larger party you
will be in for a world of pain this is
not a left right issue this happens in
both directions I know that uh vegan
activists and vegetarians who are
protesting against factory farming are
often on the receiving side of this uh
they will get some undercover footage of
you know cows being treated poorly or
whatever and they will be sued for you
know violation of Rights and trespassing
and this and that and the uh the large
uh aggro business that is doing these
lawsuits can throw you know $100,000 at
each one and they don't need to win any
of them what they need to do is force
the smaller party into just giving up
you know signing a consent decree or
handing over uh their video footage or
something and this has happened in other
directions anytime there's one small
party and one large party so um there is
something like 30 32 or 35 States right
now that have anti-s slap laws on the
books and the way these laws work is
they basically um create a cause of
action where the courts can find that
hey this isn't just a a lawsuit that
didn't succeed in its merits but this is
a lawsuit which is very clearly um
intended not to accomplish what it
claims to accomplish on its face but you
know we all know what's going on here
that you are just you know absolutely
brutalizing the smaller party so that
they cease engaging in the activism or
cease engaging in the Free Speech or
whatever it is that they're doing and
force them to give up um so that is uh
an outline of the bill um there are
model slap
legislations uh that many of the other
states have used this bill takes largely
from there there is uh another bill that
is going through committees right now
I'm not sure if it's already been held
um that has a uh unfortunately I forget
her name uh representative from the
other side of the aisle which is also an
anti-s slap uh uh proposal and we were
in discussions to see if perhaps our two
uh bills could be merged um her bill is
very much focused on one particular case
of this David versus Goliath situation
um where in domestic abuse situations
sometimes the guilty party the abuser
will sue the innocent party for saying
things out loud uh you know making
truthful statements and uh calling them
you know slander lialis um and of course
they're not truth is an absolute defense
and so this is a decent build because it
gets to the same things it gets to the
disparities where one side can afford to
just use the courts to make another side
uh give up and cease engaging in
constitutionally protected activities
like speech or like activism um during
the sort of protracted negotiations to
see if our two bills could be merged uh
we didn't get there and that was largely
because um the other uh Bill did not
have an interest in protecting um any
sorts of constitutionally protected
speech besides that very narrow one um
so um some of my uh advisers on this
said you know hey that's also a good
bill and only does 5% of what it needs
to uh accomplish um but you know I just
so you know Travis I'll be writing in
and supporting that bill because it does
something it's a small bite forward and
then you know 95% of the uh the Apple
Still Remains uh Bill uh you know aims
to get to that 90 or 95% point where it
does not uh Target the sort of abuse of
lawfare uh merely in the area of
domestic abuse although it absolutely
does cover that uh area but also covers
lots of other areas uh I welcome any
questions any
questions seeing none thank you thank
you um Chris surfit
did I get that right
close I'll take
it just push the
button is it on there we go thank you Mr
chairman and members of the committee um
Christopher suert you were very close um
I practic ised in the little town of
Franklin New Hampshire uh practice and
law since
1984 um we had the same bill last year
and you ited it and for very good reason
so we basically got the same bill again
and the same problems with this bill as
I testified to last year um in New
Hampshire you know we take very
seriously that all parties are equal
under the law and nobody gets more
rights than the other what this bill
seeks to do is give more rights to any
person claiming a violation of their
first amendment rights so we are picking
the First Amendment and given it special
privileges over our Second Amendment
rights we all think those second
amendment rights are pretty powerful our
fourth amendment rights our fifth
amendment rights the seventh the eth and
the 10th these are all the big ones you
know the right to not you know have
unreasonable search and sieges cruel and
unusual punishment right to reury Tri
you know those those are all as
important as the first amendment so this
bill seeks to elevate the First
Amendment over all those others and it
basically creates law fair it doesn't
protect to prevent law fair because
anybody under this bill who alleges that
their first amendment rights are being
stepped upon then can ask the court for
attorney fees and costs and damages of a
minimum of $10,000
we don't have any other legislation like
this in this state just don't have it we
treat all people and All rights equal
under the law that's the status quo and
that's what we should seek to do in the
future and itl this bill once again I'll
welcome any questions you may all have
any
questions seeing none thank you thank
you Mr chairman thank you members of the
committee do I hit this button again
you can leave it on that's
fine is there anyone else that wishes to
speak on House Bill
391 right here just when we thought we
were done I'm sorry no that's okay
you're all
set uh is it Marissa Chase it is all
right thank you Mr chair members just
slide that mic over sure yep there you
go can you hear me yes okay thank you Mr
chair members of the committee um for
the record my name is Marissa Chase I'm
the executive director for nhj which is
the plaintiff civil bar in New Hampshire
attorney sufor is on our board and I
agree with everything he just said I
just wanted to add a couple small items
um last year this bill was House Bill
1475 and while the sponsor is right and
I I understand his intent and think the
intent of what um he is trying to
accomplish is admirable please read the
language of the bill because the
language of the bill does not align with
that stated intent what this bill does
is create broad sweeping immunities
which those of you who have been on
Judiciary in the past I'm looking at the
four or five of you and going to make
friends for with the rest of you soon um
no that's kind that's our that's our dog
whistle uh that is a a a principle of
our organization that we fight against
immunity because if you grant someone
immunity you are saying that regardless
of what happened regardless of what
wrong has been done to you you don't get
to seek accountability to the person
that harmed you or the entity that
harmed you um there are other states
that do have anti-s slap laws that
perhaps we could work on something in
the future I think it would take a while
to get all the parties together um
including some other advocacy
organizations and I just wanted to leave
you with the blurb that um
representative Lynn chair of this
committee obviously last year wrote um
when um recommending this bill be
inexpedient to legislate was voted 20 to
nothing on consent calendar this bill
would establish certain special Court
proceed procedures for handling
so-called strategic lawsuits da da these
are lawsuits generally filed by
well-healed organizations or individuals
against generally less well healed
individuals who exercise their first
amendment rights to protest some action
or inaction taken by the formal
organizations or individuals although
the proponents of this bill asserted its
substantive merits a closed examination
shows that in the main this bill makes
procedural procedural changes to court
rules that arguably would allow such
cases to be resolved somewhat more
quickly by requiring the claimant to
produce its evidence at an earlier stage
of the case than would normally occur
this bill makes no substantive CH
substantive changes to the law the
committee was unpersuaded that slap
suits were a significant problem in New
Hampshire or the current procedures were
ineffective in addressing abuse of
litigation end quote um and then to
summarize I would just say that if you
look at the language of the bill what it
does is allows a civil defendant grants
them incredible breadth and authority
and gives the court um as attorney Su
said allows the court to stack the deck
on their side I could see civil
defendants claiming slap for a myriad of
cases to get that special treatment and
that special consideration special
weight for motions to dismiss for Ev
every procedural instance over a civil
plaintiff regardless of the playing
field so with that I don't want to stand
between you and lunch much longer any
questions seeing none thank you thank
you is there anyone else that wishes to
speak on this
bill seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing on House Bill
391 and we are in recess till
145 all caught up caught up good timing
mark thank
you
e
e e
sponsor representative Brown
please wait hold
on how's that sounds good I used the
gavl thank you Mr chairman good
afternoon committee
members my name is Pam Brown I represent
the towns of Rockingham in Rockingham
County of the towns of Kingston and East
Kingston and I'm the prime sponsor of
this bill for the record I have worked
as a full-time college professor for
almost 40 years and I'm familiar with
details of labor union contracts and
collective bargaining procedures my
campus uh education educator Union aft
1521 appointed me to serve as as their
rep on our College work environment
committee and I served for several years
on the Sanborn Regional School Board in
Kingston where I participated in labor
negotiations behind closed
doors RSA 91a ensures that deliberations
which impact our rights and our taxes
will take place as public meetings the
RSA does Grant a few exceptions to this
openness requirement including
consultations with one's legal councel
and caucus meetings of elected officials
of the same party
my bill HB 400 amends 91a to require
that meetings held between elected
officials and public labor unions to
negotiate collective bargaining
agreements shall be held as open public
meetings an identical
Bill s SP 420 was passed by our Senate
in
2018 as a school board member I am aware
that these hidden meetings produce the
bulk of our annual property taxes and
generate dozens of compulsory rules and
restrictions as a 40-year educator I
have observed secret negotiations
preserve Provisions which have never
been required to be adequately defended
in an open and transparent setting
seniority rules for example to delay or
deny promotion of significant numbers of
amazing part-time teachers and adjunct
faculty who must wait many years for
full positions hurting families who want
the most effective educator for their
children and taxpayers who want public
contracts restructured to yield the
greatest value for the dollar spent
unions have suggested bargaining should
remain confidential since they say the
process is akin to negotiating a new car
purchase engaging in marital counseling
or conducting sensitive foreign policy
discussions transparency is also
asserted to be
anti-worker public contract negotiations
aren't about top sacred issues are
sensitive private matters they concern
pay and workplace conditions
such matters are routinely discussed at
public meetings during budget hearings
wage Matrix discussions personnel and
hiring planning and RFP
reviews and unions today are open to
having their negotiations made public
Portland Washington public schools and
the Portland Association of teachers
took the initiative in 2023 and began
recording and streaming their collective
bargaining negotiations
online the nation's largest labor union
the National Education Association has
expressed support for contract
negotiations held in public in 20 a 2022
publication the benefits of collective
bargaining and public
education the Nea organization applauds
Prince jorges County Maryland Public
School Union and the PG County Educators
Association stating quote when the
Prince George's County Educators
Association sat down at the bargaining
table in 2019 it invited all 10,000
union members plus local parents parents
and students to
attend open bargaining as it's known was
a change for
pgcea but the Union's president Teresa
Dudley believes it led to a significant
improved outcome for the community and
Educators the Nea states that the open
meetings led to quote a powerful
negotiated agreement providing nearly
124 million in pay raises including 39
million toward restoring raises the
county had skipped and some members
received a 22.5% raise over 3 years my
bill simply stri strikes two words from
the RSA 91a Co 2 Section
1A the words or negotiations are removed
the amended RSA still protects the
confidential strategy sessions of
negotiating parties just as it protects
strategy sessions of political
caucuses transparency and public
collective bargaining encourag honest
debate and strongly crafted defensible
contracts in addition it allows
communities to be included and share
informed opinions with both
parties and I'll take questions if you
have any are there any questions
representative Perez I just want to make
sure I understand so when my town
somebody from the Town Council on the
lawyer and stuff go into bargain for the
fire
department you want that to be public a
public meeting is that what you're
saying saying the two parties when they
meet together to discuss the contract
that would be a public meeting if the
parties are are planning strategies each
party is allowed to confidentially plan
their strategy but when they meet
together it should be public meeting so
actually when were they're actually
negotiating yes it would be a public
meeting correct that's a great
idea any other
questions representative Horgan yes
thank you very much I I see there's a
representative from the NH Nea so have
you discussed his position with him or I
don't know if he's going to fill out a
pink car and testify or not but do you
know if do you know if nhna agrees
position on this is the same as what you
ascribed I'm not sure of the the New
Hampshire Nea chapter but um the
national Nea has expressed interest in
open meetings um hope hopefully they'll
they'll support the national
position oh thanks if they want to
submit some I mean they might they might
want to email us some like just
confirmation that yes so um just so you
could it would be possible to have them
you know send us some documentation to
clarify that that is indeed their
position so they
certainly representative Andress thank
you Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question I am totally for this bill I
have a lot to do with my school district
my question is do you know
why Union
contracts are not allowed to be given to
the public prior to us voting on the
contract I
was I don't know does that have any
really to do with this bill I don't
think it's yeah
well as a member of the public and also
as a school uh budget Committee Member
when I wanted to see contracts about to
be placed on as warrant articles I've
always been able to get a copy to view
the the
draft representative
Manos thank you Mr chair and thank you
Miss representative Brown I'm I'm
confused about the language
because um this is in a list
of what is not considered a public
meeting correct yes so you would have it
your proposal your bill is that strategy
with respect to collective
bargaining where only one of the
negotiating parties is present so I'm
con I'm I'm confused about what it is
exactly you want to be public and what
it is exactly you want to have
remain um not subject to
disclosure so the public meeting aspect
would be when the two parties are have
are meeting together to negotiate or
discuss the contract
Provisions when they're to when they're
separate and in their own meetings to
strategize on their positions they would
have the ability to have a meeting in in
private as a confidential meeting but
when they meet together in a public as a
as two parties they would be um meeting
in a public set setting an open meeting
followup thank you but doesn't the
strategy where only one negotiating
party is present so how are you going to
have a strategy session where only
one where only one party where only one
party is I'm I'm not I'm still not
understanding exactly I might be able to
clarify that a bit so a union gets the
the members of the Union would
strategize about what they want to see
uh negotiated during negotiations so
when they're meeting it's kind of like a
caucus so it's the members of the Union
that are meeting to say this is what we
want this is what we'll accept we won't
take that so that's what that separation
is if that yes that seem like an answer
all
right uh representative uh
Paige thank you thank you Mr chair and
thanks for taking my question this is an
interesting
concept I'm I'm wondering if um part of
the um part of the intent of the bill is
to get at perhaps bargaining agreements
that um maybe the people in the local
school district don't ultimately agree
with and if that's
so would the remedy be more not coming
to us but to ask the voters the voters
do ultimately see the contract and if
they're upset with the terms or feel
like it's not being leveraged to
whatever Advantage whatever side or
whatever wouldn't that be more
consistent with allowing local control
and voters to have a say to excuse the
expression vote the bumps out at the
school board or
whatever well I suppose local voters
could
perhaps Advance the idea that their
local unions should be negotiating in
public as public meetings but I feel
that it's a fundamental right that as
taxpayers and as Citizens we be allowed
to see public sector negotiations
conducted in a public setting so that we
can appreciate both sides of the
arguments and maybe even contribute
input when we hear the arguments
presented in a strong manner in a public
setting I don't want to specify
any um history or any details of past
negotiations I've seen as an educator
but often times small Provisions are
made to to satisfy the needs of a
segment or a small number of um
participants either on one team or the
other and it doesn't provide
transparency to have the contracts
formed in a closed setting where we
don't truly understand where the origins
of these results are coming from if it's
in a public setting we can better
understand exactly why the contract
Provisions are being formed as they are
and understand both sides of the
arguments representative forg
thank you very much I remember this bill
coming to the community several years
ago before you were there and I remember
the problem I had a time would seemed to
me um we can't the union the Union's
bargaining committee can meet privately
because they're not subject to 91a
they're private organization so they're
not even covered by 91a but the bargain
you know the bargaining committee on the
management side um it's part of a public
body so I see the unless they
unless they don't do some sneaky thing
like hiring a a unless they do find some
sneaky work around their public bodies
that are covered by 91a so doesn't I'm
concerned that might Place Management at
a competitive disadvantage because the
union you know the union bargaining
committee can speak frankly amongst
themselves and nobody's listening in but
the other hand the management bargaining
commiss committee they have to have
everything in in Open Session which may
or may may not necessarily cause a
better result I mean I feel like anyway
so is that uh do you understand the
question yes so is that the accurate
thing that the the union that the
management bargaining committees would
now no longer be able to meet and meet
privately and do you feel that that
might place them at a competitive
disadvantage with the Union side of
it well as I understand it when we have
negotiations with public sector unions
both part both parties management and
the union Representatives can meet as
groups to discuss their strategy and how
they would like to see the contract uh
formed so I don't understand exactly how
the bill would prevent or inhibit either
side from benefiting from private
negotiate secret or not confidential
negotiations in a group by themselves
versus meeting together in
public representative Alexander thank
you Mr chair thank you representative
I'm right here I'm taking your question
I don't I didn't see um so can you
clarify this for me if this bill
passes a quorum of the select board can
still meet in non-public to discuss
strategy on
negotiating with a
union well I've never actually
encountered the issue of a quorum for
the select board for our our school
board um we had a subset of school board
members representing um the district and
it was not a quorum of those people it
was was a group of three but to follow
up that would be considered strategy
though yes right if so if if three of
the five members of the gtown select
board met to talk strategy about a union
negotiation
negotiation they could go into
non-public still under this law they
just couldn't go into non-public for the
negotiation but just the strategy
component um that sounds right to me um
I hadn't really considered that aspect
if it was a quorum or not but they do go
into non-public to discuss um the
negotiations
yes any other
questions representative
Bergeron and thank you in advance for
your
information I was just curious because
you mentioned Nea and I'm on a school
board as well and we have a great
relationship with Nea but do they fall
under a public body
where their negotiations would have to
be recorded as well Nea so in other
words we could look at their recording
and I don't know use it to our advantage
vice versa so I'm just wondering how
that
works well if your Nea um
representatives are meeting to
strategize they would not be recorded
that would be a confidential meeting so
that will be because of the strategize
part right
okay yes thank thank you representative
trip thank you thank you for taking my
question uh it's interesting you said
that uh when the uh School Board is
negotiating with the whatever
uh Union that they're negotiating that
they they there's usually only
three uh that's the same way it is in in
uh in Dairy when uh our school board
negotiates but uh they they have an
official uh negotiating committee
subcommittee and I'm just wondering
would you consider uh the lack of a
Schoolboard
Quorum
uh since it's it's a uh a quorum for the
negotiating committee would you consider
that to be a public
meeting that's a good question I would
say as um the body that is in engaged in
nego negotiations with the
Union they will be planning their own
strategies for those sessions and
according to the RSA Str as we designed
it um in
hp400 those strategy sessions could be
held as a non- meeting as a strategy
session so I don't believe as a
negotiating team they would be
considered um a quorum of the school
board and subject to a public
meeting thank you I imagine if there's a
subcommittee assigned strictly for
negotiations that subcommittee would
have its own Quorum its own numbers for
quorums as we do here so I don't know if
that
helps I imagine it would be but that's
my opinion uh representative
Andros thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question do you know if there
are any other New Hampshire laws
regarding unions and negotiations which
might be in conflict with passings this
bill I do not but I can try to find out
if there are any such
conflicts um I'm I'm not aware of
any are there any other
questions seeing none thank you thank
you so much
is it Scott
goie yep from
teamers just turn on the microphone
and Mr chairman members of the committee
my name is Scott Gober I represent
Teamsters in New
Hampshire I'm going to try to be
brief this bill HP 400 will slow down
the bargaining process
people will perform for public
consumption more than they'll complete
the bargaining process for the good of
the public private information may be
shared in the public
space it will cost the public money to
publish and live stream these
conversations and bargaining proceedings
and final contracts are
already part of the record the public
record um I'll take any questions that
anyone might have any questions
representative forez so why do you think
this is important to some
people well you hear the word secret
used a lot we don't operate in secret
we're very forthright with what as far
as the teamsters go when we go into
negotiations what we're after um as far
as what I believe I I think people want
to interject into that into to that
system uh from the outside there are
elected people that you've entrusted to
negotiate with the teamsters or any
other Union and I think that the trust
should be put in them to negotiate I
also feel that it may drive those
conversations further away from the body
instead of being in the room okay thank
you any other
questions seeing none thank you thank
you
Doug uh Doug
inol good afternoon uh my name is Doug
ingersol I'm the executive director of
the Public Employee Labor Relations
Board which is the board the State Board
responsible for administering RSA 273a
which is the states collective
bargaining law been with the board since
2006 and the uh public sector collective
bargaining law has been in effect uh
since
1976 and in terms of the issue being
discussed today um it has never been
part of the bargaining process I do have
I'm only here today to to give
you uh some some statistics about the
contracts that we have um a little
information about the bargaining process
so that you understand what the steps
are
um and to and to point
out some legislative history or
legislative activity back in 2011 that
relates to this the same topic
so in terms of uh collective bargaining
agreements today all collective
bargaining Agreements are supposed to be
filed with the
plrb within two weeks uh of being
signed um all of those Agreements are
ultimately published on our
website uh as well as all orders and
decisions the board has issued since
1976 um currently we have approximately
6 20 collective bargaining agreements on
file uh and if you factor in that the
state Master agreement
covers 25 individual bargaining units uh
that number is actually closer to
645 bargaining units
which relates to uh approximately 650
bargaining unit certifications that are
uh currently on file of those 600 20
bargaining units all of them are current
meaning they haven't hit their
expiration date by expiration date I
mean for example uh commonly in teacher
contracts it's June 30 but for example a
education contract with an expiration
date of 6 June 30 2025 would be
considered
current um 43 of those 620 contracts
have
expired uh on a percentage basis that
means that 93% of the contracts on file
which we which I believe is a pretty
comprehensive inventory of the contracts
uh currently in place in the state 93%
are current and only 7% have
expired that is a uh a very good
percentage of current contracts versus
expired contracts compared to the
history 101 15 years ago obviously those
percentages can fluctuate
depending on a variety of factors um and
I have distributed today a list of the
43 expired
contracts I also have a 16-page
spreadsheet which I'm not going to hand
out today but which I can submit to the
board of all 620 contracts if you were
interested in in going through that
information but if you look at the uh
handout of the 43 expired you'll notice
that a lot of those expired contracts
expired in
2024 and a lot of those expired December
31st of
2024 which means that there may be new
contracts in place yet which haven't
made it to our office uh and another
large category is June 30 uh
2024 not every employer uh and every
Union um files their contracts in a
timely manner we go hunting for them
from time to time on uh public employer
websites and then we contact public
employers um as well that's a ongoing
process um so my input is that the
current system of bargaining seems to be
working very well uh we do get unfair
labor practices in our office which uh
require contested hearings and sometimes
those cases relate to the bargaining
process um I would say the number of
those types of cases in the last few
years is
uh not that there was uh an accessibly
high number before but they periodically
uh would come in
um I I think the only other two things I
want to say are some comments about
House Bill 580 which was filed in
2011 and then just to briefly mention
the steps in the bargaining process uh
so beginning with the steps in the
bargaining process um there three basic
steps uh negotiations ratification and
then cost item approvals by the local
legislative body for example uh at town
meeting so in terms of negotiations uh
the unions and the public employer uh
board are free to structure those as
they see fit uh some employers employ uh
an attorney to conduct all
negotiations uh some have a bargaining
team which may consist of a
representative from a board of Selectmen
uh an HR person who has
information uh relevant to negotiations
and then perhaps also an attorney uh
likewise for the unions uh for not to
pick on the Nea but uh they have
uniserve directors for various regions
in the state they may work on some
contracts uh and sometimes the employees
with who have experience in the process
handle the neg iations on their
own it's possible that uh a quorum of a
public board uh conven to conduct
negotiations and my understanding of uh
RSA
91a uh and I've been an attorney since
1989 and I think that law is fairly
clear in the first
paragraph uh the public meeting
requirements and the notice requirements
apply if there is a quorum of a public
board
meeting uh and
my understanding of that law uh would be
that for example if you had a five
member Board of Selectmen and you had
three members of that board meeting for
any reason that that would be considered
a quorum which would be sufficient to
trigger uh all the public meeting notice
protections and requirements that are in
91a I know there was a comment that if
there was a subcommittee then if uh that
subcommittee had a quorum present that
that could trigger as well I'm the I'm
not here to offer an opinion on that I
don't I've never encountered that and
I'm not saying whether that's correct or
not uh but my understanding of the law
is that um you do need a a a quorum of
the full board in order to trigger the
public meeting requirement same thing is
true with my board
um so onto the uh negotiation process
the goal of the parties is to reach a
tenative agreement and they are under
strict uh deadline
uh and if you were interested in
visiting our website and went to the
FAQs you'll find a
um document which has all the applicable
deadlines in the bargaining process and
and those deadlines are all based on the
budget submission date uh and in the
case of town meeting uh there there
needs to be ample opportunity to get any
new contract the cost items of any new
contract on a warrant article so that it
gets presented at Town meeting because
if that deadline is missed then uh for
most public employers that tenative
agreement and those cost items will not
be in front of that uh local legislative
body for another year I think for school
districts there may be an opportunity to
petition for um a special meeting if
those deadlines are missed so so it is a
time-sensitive
process uh parties are required to meet
uh at reasonable times and place places
which includes during the
workday uh if there are if this process
is subject to the requirements of 91a
you would have to factor in uh public
notice requirements uh maybe
considerations of venue uh because if
it's a public meeting now then not only
does it need to be noticed but it would
need to be held in an environment where
it could be accessed either in person or
um through video
feed um so the parties are under
pressure to to reach a tenative
agreement um they typically work off of
the existing contract there was
discussion about what's the difference
between when the parties are at the
bargaining table and that's the
expression we use when they're facing
each other when they're at the
bargaining table and and how does that
differ from when they Retreat to their
own own quarters to decide how to
proceed um one
when they're at the bargaining table
they're dealing with each other and I
think the the hope of this bill is to
expose that part and make it subject to
91a uh but when they caucus out of the
presence of the other party then that
would not be subject to any
91a uh
requirements if they reach a tenative
agreement uh then the next step is
ratification uh the UN the unions
typically will present the tenative
agreement to to the employees in the
bargaining unit for a vote and the
bargaining team for the employer will go
back to the board of Selectmen for
example and present the tenative
agreement both sides need to approve
that in order for them the agreement
either become final or if there is are
cost items also known as new money then
the cost items would need to be approved
for example a town meeting for the
contract to become final uh T town town
meeting doesn't vote on the rest of the
contract and there are a number of New
Hampshire State Supreme Court decisions
on that point under the current law if
the parties are unable to come up with a
a tenative agreement they're said to be
a bargaining impass and there are formal
procedures that they have to follow to
try to break that impass there's
contract mediation and fact finding uh
we have a list of what are called
neutrals who work in that area parties
petition us for the appointment if they
can't agree on somebody on their own and
they go through that process and either
through
mediation uh which is not a uh
individual excuse me if you could just
focus on the on the particulars of this
bill okay not the whole negotiation
process so okay I thought that might be
helpful for the context uh obviously I'm
not here
uh to recommend is in terms of policy
what what the committee how the
committee proceeds um the last thing I
wanted to mention was in 2011 House Bill
580 essentially proposed the same thing
uh there the the bill was referred to
study committee uh there were six study
committee meetings um and I researched
that bill before I came here I I think I
did it a month ago and there is I think
a 79 or 80 page report on file that you
can access which has the results of that
the committee recommendations
uh they did not
adopt the proposal that's in this bill
but they did make some minor changes to
to 73a for
example um they added a step in
bargaining impass to allow with
agreement either party to make a
presentation directly to for example all
of the employees in the bargaining unit
or all the members of the board involved
and the objective of that was to try to
take action that might help the parties
get contracts done um because I think
there was a sense back then that if
there was more information available it
might uh it might enhance the potential
to reach an
agreement I I'll stop there any
questions seeing none thank you thank
you Brian Hawkins
uh thank you Mr chairman uh members of
the committee for the record Brian
Hawkins uh representing Nea New
Hampshire uh we represent um uh numerous
K uh 12 bargaining units uh across the
state and um and some of which uh were
referenced in earlier testimony uh we're
here in opposition to the bill uh our
concern here and this has come up before
the legislature before uh as director
inera mentioned it's been uh I think
voted down at least a couple of times in
the last decade uh we're worried that
this uh will slow the process uh down as
far as the negotiating process as was
mentioned earlier um the parties are
under some very strict timelines uh to
get uh something to put before their
respective uh voting bodies whether it's
the school board and the and the union
membership or or whichever public body
that is um especially when you're
talking about cost items because those
those obviously have to go before the
voters and so the voters do see those as
you know um they're going to be seeing a
number of them uh in just a few weeks
here uh in March so so um it's hard
enough I think um especially with some
of the workforce challenges that we have
today um to schedule and make the time
to even get the process going and to
have a schedule uh and I mean that not
only for the employees but for the for
the employer as well um and so uh this
adds another layer to that um the other
thing that I want to mention um as I
said before you know the these uh
anything that has to do with a cost item
do have to go before the voters which
they can vote down um and as far as
having an open meeting our position is
that should be a decision made by the
two
parties um when they're establishing the
ground rules of of of going in and so um
for those reasons uh we uh we oppose the
bill and uh happy to take any
questions any questions representative
menos thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question so the parties
aside from from the statute and the
proposed changes the parties could agree
to do their bargaining in
public uh that yes uh there's nothing
stopping them from doing that um if they
wanted to um you know I think uh one of
the things that has been is helpful is
to be able to like I said with tight
timelines is really you know getting
down to those just like in the
legislature you know when you're having
a committee of conference there's what
happens here and then there's the actual
negotiation um and so uh and that's
just that's just you know uh so um I
think that in in this instance as as I
said when there's um you don't this
could actually have the opposite effect
of driving further those conversations
where it's you know U sort of behind the
scenes if that's what the goal was so um
hope that helps answer the
question any other questions
representative
Andress thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question can the voters
themselves like in the school district
vote to have it public
uh not to my knowledge but I I'll be
honest I uh there's probably somebody
else who could better answer whether
there's some law that uh um indicates
whether they can or not so I I don't
want to I don't want to give you
information that's that's not accurate
okay thank you representative Alexander
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question I think representative
Andrews asks a great question would Nea
New Hampshire support a bill enabling
towns to adopt opt the open negotiation
process through a town
warrant through a town warrant Town
warrant
article
yeah I think I think this is I think
this goes to the to sort of the role of
the way uh the 273a is set up so you
have the negotiation sessions and then
it is the cost items that go before the
voters as director angol said before so
uh it's the responsibility of the
parties to have that negotiations and
bring before their respective bodies an
agreement so if you are now saying that
the legislative body is going to uh sort
of impact that process I don't I don't
think that that is the right um approach
in uh it sort of it sort of mixes the
the the two processes together and I I I
I'm not sure that that would be helpful
again I'm coming here to say as as a
policy matter for the
legislature uh I I think you want to
have these agreements before voters as I
said there is huge Workforce challenges
not only in education but in law
enforcement in uh firefighting and so
having um those negotiation sessions
produce an agreement that's going to
allow your um Community to not only
recruit but retain Cur employees I think
that that ought to be the goal and of
course as I said that goes before the
voters ultimately um every
March I I so I guess I I'm guess I'm
asking if this if this was amended to
allow towns to put or or a voters to put
a petition warrant article to mandate
that their negotiations are done in
public so it's a local option I guess
I'm wondering
would you still be opposed to it because
it the I mean the local voters are the
ones
that have the say at the end of the day
so yeah I I think we would still be
opposed to it because again the product
that is the purview of the legislative
body uh goes before those voters they
they get that on the whether it's the
warrant or the traditional town meeting
um or in the city council form of
government they get they get that
product and that um ultimately is is
what is um voted on so I think that's
the right balance representative paig
thank you uh Mr chairman thanks for
taking my question piggybacking off of
um representative Anderson the theme
here about legislative involvement in
this and this may surprise some of my
colleagues but I think I'm going to
strike a conservative tone here and um
for limited government and I wonder if
this scenario is possible if a candidate
running for school board made it their
platform that they wanted to be open and
transparent with
negotiations would that remove the
legislature from any of this business
and allow the voters directly to decide
about that issue and how contract
negotiations take place in their um town
or wherever do you follow my question
I'm not I'm sorry representative I'm not
sure I do so taking out the legislative
idea of giving a opin or whatever
wouldn't a more direct vote a direct
route to get the voter
sentiment be a candidate for running for
school board to pledge that their
motivating force is to open up contract
negotiations and then the voters could
have that decision I think that could be
a more direct route or even a more
direct route would be you know that that
is something that they want their
negotiating team to explore when they
are establishing the ground rules
so any other
questions seeing none thank you thank
you Sarah Burke
Cohen good afternoon my name is Sarah
Burke Cohen I represent the New
Hampshire Municipal Association
um we are opposed to uh this bill um
collective bargaining negotiations have
always been exempt from the right to a
law and should continue to be so um try
I'll try not to um reiterate what some
of my previous colleagues have said um
the ability to negotiate in private
Fosters compromise I think that's a key
ingredient to
negotiations uh requiring public bodies
and unions representatives to hold
negoti negotiating sessions in public
likely could lead to grandstanding and
hardening of additions on both sides
which would increase the amount of time
um and to take to get to an agreement
delaying the agreement and it would
increase the amount of cost to
municipalities um for those negotiating
sessions I think the other thing to
consider is um drawing a sharp
distinction between strategy and
negotiations can be difficult in the
public meeting process um if you're in a
public meeting it would be sort of being
in compliance with 91a and making sure
you are popping from public meeting back
to um a non- me a nonpublic session and
back back into public meeting um could
make a recordkeeping near
impossible finally if it's the goal of
uh the bill for more open process um
potentially this uh could uh would not
work just by virtue of I think what we
were getting at with the subcommittees
and the Quorum um there is also a
possibility that a subcommittee could
appoint one single person to be The
Negotiator um and those negotiations
then would no longer be um would no
longer fall under 91a because it
wouldn't be a a quum of the public body
um I'll take questions representative
Alexander thank you Mr chair and thank
you great to see you again um would nhma
support the legislation if we made it a
local
option I would love to see that language
representative Alexander And if you
would like to send it to us I'm sure we
can take a look at it good answer thank
representative
Horgan um yes I was wondering you know
the this supplies only the management
because they're they're a public body
the Union Local isn't but would it
workaround if we did pass this could
some public uh could the some public
employers try to get around it by just
turning over the nuts and Bolson
negotiation over to a lawyer or some
other third party who's not a public
body and therefore not found by
91a I think that's what I was somewhat
saying that if there is not a quorum of
the public body if there's a
subcommittee and they appoint one single
person a selectman or a school board
member to do the negotiations there
wouldn't be a quum of the public body so
it wouldn't be a a public
meeting any other questions
seeing none thank you you're
welcome uh Reverend Dr Gail
Kenny button yeah thank you thank you um
good afternoon for the record again my
name is Gail Kenny I'm a resident of
Kanan New Hampshire um I uh wanted to
speak just for a minute or two on this
bill um because I have been on both
sides both as an employe sitting at the
table both as an employer and as an
employee over um the times I've been
alive and I I just urge you to think
about any negotiation that you have been
involved in a negotiation for a contract
or something which is a give and take
process where people on on both sides
are on offering their desires and then
you come to compromise and then you
ultimately come to an agreement and if
there is a policy that when you're
involved in sensitive contract
negotiations which require give and take
that anybody whether they have a um an a
financial interest or that anybody who
wants to can sit in on those
negotiations um whether they have a
direct connection or not will that
Foster positive productive negotiations
or will it not um in this particular
case with public bodies that are working
with and trying to to deal with making
decisions employment decisions are
around wages um benefits and conditions
of employment for their employees and
likewise for the employees doing the
same thing you want to get to a contract
resolution that can then be presented to
the
municipality um or the the public entity
uh School District Etc um as efficiently
as possible as effectively as possible
and as positively as possible
and the way to do that is for the
parties to be able to come together
uh to really do that kind of give and
take um without there being um a large
audience which um every I trust me
everybody who is involved in the
negotiations if they have a larger
audience of people who have a variety of
different interests or no interests you
know
on there's you're aware you're aware of
what you're saying to that that public
public audience and and for um public
employers are elected school board
members elected select board people you
are well aware that the things that
you're saying may have an impact on your
ability to be reelected that is just
reality and that is not the best way to
reach positive productive negotiations
to get to a contract that's fair for
everybody and so this this particular
proposal again has been studied before
and has been recognized as maybe not
being in the best interest of all sides
and I would encourage you to again
realize that this is not the best way to
achieve good contracts for the public
good and to find this inexpedient to
legislate any
questions representative
Manos thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question um have you had
experience where it's either been more
than one public body involved in the
negotiation or more than one Union
involved in the negotiation and what are
the Dynamics like in that situation and
your
experience more than one
public body I'm thinking not directly
involved in the negotiation session but
I don't you know I can't speak to every
public sector situation and I don't
really know um there are um you just
take the state of New Hampshire for
example in contract negotiations there
are a number of different unions um that
are involved um overall working for the
State of New Hampshire there are some um
and again and I I am not an expert on
the the state contracts and so I'm not
speaking for the state employees or for
the state and government itself but um
there are some master agreements or some
overarching foundational um tenants that
that may involve several different
unions uh for a public body um but then
there are separate negotiations that
would involve each individual Union so
sort of
subnations around some sort of Master
tenants um
but you don't want to make it any more
complicated you want to get to positive
efficient conclusions to contract
negotiations not to to um throw a monkey
wrench into the works to make them more
difficult which I believe this would
do are there any other
questions seeing none thank
you that's the last card I have for
someone to speak on this bill is anyone
else that wishes to speak on House Bill
400 that has not
spoken seeing none I'm going to close
the hearing on House Bill
400 and we are at that time so we can
open up the hearing on House Bill 601 FN
and I recognize the prime sponsor
representative
Reed thank you Mr chair thank you
honorable members of the Judiciary
Committee um
hp601 first of all has a faulty
analysis um it says that the bill does
two things creates a private cause of
action against companies that misstate
the impacts of their business on the
environment and then criminal P
penalties for that it does not create
new Criminal penalties um it does create
essentially in effect two different
private rights of action one for
misstating the impacts of your business
on the environment which falls under the
consumer protection act deceptive
practices which is probably broadly
interpreted to include that anyway but
um it creat Ates a new private right of
action against fossil fuel companies for
the uh their proportion of Damages in a
climate
disaster so those are the two things
that the bill does not what it
says so um it will be a surprise to no
one here that in general I support
regulation of businesses when it comes
to their impacts on the environment
however traditionally historically
conventionally the arguments go thusly
while people may be on the left side of
things like myself say we should
regulate businesses before they do
damage typically what we've heard in
response on from the more conservative
uh philosophy is no no let let the free
market play out and if there are damages
done let it all kind of come out in the
wash in the courts so if a company is
hurting the environment hurting people
doing bad things you can sue them and
get damages and then eventually that
will become a deterrent for Bad actors
because they will be paying so much in
the damages that they will stop doing
that and that's kind of the theory of
how the free market is supposed to work
under um kind of unfettered free market
philosophy so knowing that um perhaps my
idea of regulating businesses may not be
incredibly popular at the moment if if
the solution is to allow this to play
out in the courts then let's allow it to
play out in the courts let's allow
people to sue for the damages that are
done by companies who damage
us
so now private rights of action as will
come as no surprise to any of you there
are thousands upon thousands of examples
um many in this state but across the the
country of new private rights of action
being created most recently when it
comes to the tech industry and privacy
concerns and all of that but this is
something that we do regularly in order
to allow consumers in particular
consumers but other people to protect
themselves so I want to get to the two
pieces the first piece is what I call
the green washing piece and this is the
idea that under the consumer protection
act we have deceptive practices claimed
typically these um while the government
can enforce these typically what happens
is it goes to a civil suit usually by a
business against another business for
claiming that they are doing something
good and therefore by comparison the
business filing the claim is saying they
are being harmed because this other
business is claiming that they're better
than they actually are so very
frequently this is how this is actually
enforced is through actual civil suits
um this is expanding that to say and a
particular deceptive practice is known
as greenwashing and here's the
definition of
brainwashing specifically most
importantly around claims around Net
Zero because a lot of those claims are
very
deceptive in
practice so that is just that just
basically clarifying the deceptive
practices in the consumer protection act
it is not creating any new Criminal
penalties that are not already in the
consumer protection act the second piece
of it is the private right of action
against companies fossil fuel companies
in particular that um have contributed
to climate disaster there are very
definite definitions of which companies
you can sue what the thresholds are and
what the threshold for a climate
disaster is so for example you can only
Sue in this scenario if you have
experienced say you're a farmer and
there's a storm that destroys your farm
if you have at least $110,000 of
damage you can only sue a company that
has output at least 1 billion metric
tons of carbon since 1965 for the record
there is no new hampshire-based company
that meets that threshold there are
plenty of companies that operate in New
Hampshire not based in New Hampshire
that meet that threshold but no New
Hampshire company would fall under
this however companies that have harmed
New Hampshire citizens and new
businesses would be subjected to this um
there is also definitions for what would
meet a climate disaster depending on the
severity of the disaster and the event
does it exceed the averages that have
historically existed for those types of
disasters that being one of the
things it's extremely important to note
that there has to be as we are engaging
in more and more climate disasters or
disas however you want to put
it that we are quick quickly reaching
the threshold as we just saw in
California with the fires we are quickly
reaching the threshold of what insurance
companies will deal with they will bail
as it gets worse and worse and so we
need to allow people to have especially
these people in particular experiencing
over $10,000 of damage to have a way to
recoup those costs here in this state
also what the plaintiff would be suing
for would be proportional to that
company's contribution to overall carbon
um emissions as fossil fuel
companies so that's kind of the overview
the the 30,000 foot
View and I guess I'll kind of stop there
because this is a fairly dense and Big
Bill and a huge kind of scope kind of
lofty uh goal but I'm I'm happy to
engage with committee members um either
on the details or on the the
philosophy representative tur yeah
thanks and thanks for taking the
question does is this based on anything
that any other state has done or does
this exist in any other um state in the
country in a similar form thank you very
much they yes many many states have put
forward both elements though not
together I'm doing private right of
action on both green washing and on
climate disaster I kind of put them
together kind of to more to get the
conversation started on this um but both
have been put forward by multiple States
at least a half dozen um I do have uh
someone in the audience representing a a
a group the center for climate Integrity
that I conferred with when writing the
Bill who can probably give more specific
examples of which states Pennsylvania I
know is one of them
any other
questions seeing none thank you thank
you Mike
Mino thank you Mr chairman and members
of the committee uh good afternoon my
name is Mike Mino I live in Lebanon New
Hampshire with my wife and two children
and I'm also the communications director
for the center for climate Integrity
we're a nonprofit that empowers
communities and official with tools and
research to hold major oil and gas
corporations accountable for deceiving
the public about how their products fuel
climate change for decades the world's
biggest oil and gas companies have
internally known that the unabated use
of their fossil fuel products could lead
to in the words of one Exxon scientist
potentially catastrophic events instead
of disclosing these risks to the public
and helping to usher in the transition
to cleaner and cheaper forms of energy a
growing body of evidence shows how the
fossil fuel industry deliberately sought
to discredit science promote climate
denial and deceive the public and policy
makers about the very real threats they
knew the continued use of their products
posed to our economy ecosystems and
public health like tobacco and opioid
companies major oil companies lied about
the harms of their products in order to
protect their own
profits today these same companies
continue to deceive consumers through
misleading advertisements that seek to
portray their businesses as
environmentally friendly last year
members of Congress told the US
Department of Justice that a yearslong
investigation found that companies
including Exxon Chevron shell and BP
quote worked in concert to mislead the
public policy makers and investors with
public promises to reduce emissions and
meaningfully contribute to the
transition away from oil and gas while
privately seeking to lock in continued
fossil fuel production for decades into
the
future state and local governments
across the US have turned to the Core to
hold major fossil fuel companies
accountable for this deception and make
them pay for the damage it has caused in
November Maine became the ninth US state
and the fifth in New England to file a
climate deception lawsuit against big
oil companies for quote failing to warn
Mayers and concealing their knowledge
about the devastating consequences of
the increasing use of fossil fuels on
Maine's people economy and
environment New Hampshire's residents
and businesses are also suffering from
the consequences of big oils climate
deception sea level rise along the Sea
Coast stronger and more damaging storms
across the state an increase and
dangerous extreme heat days and warmer
and wetter Winters that threaten many of
our traditions and industries have all
been linked to global warming caused by
fossil fuel pollution the people of New
Hampshire deserve Pathways to hold
accountable those bad corporate actors
whose decades long dishonesty and
deception has fueled these damages House
Bill 601 would give us the tool to do
exactly that this important legislation
would help Define and deter some of the
most common forms of misleading
environmental claims commonly known as
greenwashing it would help consumers
make informed purchasing decisions and
establish consequences for companies
that knowingly deceive New Hampshire
residents about their impact on the
environment and it would create a
pathway for residents business owners
and others who have suffered monitary
damages as a result of climate disasters
fueled by corporate deception to recover
their losses in court at the end of the
day this bill is about fairness
companies cannot lie to Consumers about
their harmful products and those that
have suffered losses as a result of
corporate misconduct should have an
Avenue to seek Justice through the
courts I urge the committee to support
House Bill 601 thank you any
questions seeing none thank
you that's the last card I had for that
bill is anyone else wish to speak on
it seeing none I'm going to close the
public public hearing on House Bill
601 and we have some time before the
next one there was some questions about
what order are in there is I guess
there's been some revised schedules put
out but this is the order that is on the
website as well so they're in proper
order yeah
there a big one coming up right
no I why
being that's
interesting it's interesting
for
e
e e
3:15 so I'm going to open up the hearing
on House Bill 485 and recognize
representative Ron dun to introduce the
Bill thank you Mr chair good afternoon
Mr chair committee members and guests
I'm representative Ron dun from lonere
I'm here today to sponsor a bill that
will allow individuals to remain
anonymous when winning the lottery if
they meet the following criteria the
winner must be a victim of domestic
violence the winner has to be active
restraining order against another
person or the commissioner of the
lottery has determined that it would be
in the best interest of the winner to
remain
anonymous this bill would allow the
commissioner to know who won the lottery
but would not require him to to release
the name of the winner
publicly the winner of the lottery would
also not be required to put money into a
trust to remain anonymous in current law
this is the only way for a winner to
remain
anonymous I met with the lottery
commissioner Charlie McIntyre when
drafting this bill to get the language
right
one of his main concerns was that he
would not know who the winner was this
bill fixes
that by amending 91a the current and
future Lottery Commissioners will be
allowed to use their best judgment to
allow a lottery winner to remain
anonymous if they feel it necessary for
the well-being and safety of the
individual this is a simple change to
existing law that will protect
those who win the lottery and fear for
their safety or well-being if they were
to come forward to claim a prize
thank you for your time today I'd be
happy to take any questions any
questions representative Perez thank you
thanks for taking my
question this doesn't take away for
other people to be able to remain
anonymous by putting it in a trust is
that correct thank you for the question
it does not followup followup why not a
bill that no one has to re no one
everyone can remain anonymous thank you
for the question
I did that last term representative
Perez and it was determined by the
lottery that they felt like everybody
remaining Anonymous aot prevented them
from advertising and from them basically
being transparent that everybody wins a
lottery so when I met with the
commissioner he he felt like this was a
good resolution um to my concerns and to
his any other questions representative
Tura this one is is there any examples
in the past of where this kind of thing
has presented a
problem uh thank you for the question um
the commissioner told myself when I met
with him that he has done this for a few
individuals in the past and he thinks
it'd be best to put this into statute
because that way future Lottery
Commissioners would have it at their
disposal
also any other questions seeing none
thank
you uh representative Henry is it Json G
no I
know thank you Mr chair honorable
representatives for record
representative Henry gon Hillsboro 29th
District so one of the things that I try
to remind the body of anytime I talk to
uh to the body is that it's the
responsibility of this body of the
legislative body to defend the rights of
the people and that includes the right
to privacy um I agree with I agree with
you honorable representative that I
would love to see this go further into
to privacy for all people but as the
bill is presented right now this does
create privacy for victims or would be
victims of domestic
violence um of single parents who are
avoiding a hostile a hostile exp parent
Etc and so it's very important that we
are taking into account the safety of
our citizens and prudently announcing
publicly that somebody who may have been
at risk now is the inher Itor of a lot
of money or the recipient rather didn't
inherit it they received it um does
create its own risk including for people
who are not victims so I think that this
is a good start but I would like to see
it expanded on in the future and I fully
support this bill as it stands now any
questions seeing none thank
you is there anyone else that wishes to
speak on this bill it hasn't turned into
pink card you have to fill out a pink
card store but you can do that when
you're done if you want to testify first
and then fill that out and turn it in
you just state your name for the record
sir SE turn the mic on push the
button push a uh there's a button on the
front oh Sor there you go okay Sean
Faber London der um I'm speaking in
favor of this bill there's been past
cases I've seen one in Australia where a
non-custodial parent had actually
kidnapped the their child because
someone had won the lottery um this is
something that 18 other states have um
we have a constitutional right to
privacy in this state I think that we
should have it in in uh codified in the
law in this instance um it's a safety
hazard um you can get any kind of
domestic violence case where someone
just shows up at the door they suddenly
know where the person lives if they've
been trying to keep to themselves um
it's an area where we really don't want
to get into lawsuit territory with this
this also prevents the state from having
to incur any kind of Damages there was a
lawsuit in miramac in 2018 um towards
the state lottery which they lost in
court so I also do think this bill
should be expanded but just for this
limited scope to get something in there
for the citizens I think it's something
that we really should be doing so I
speak in favor of this bill uh any
questions any questions at all
representative
Andress thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question okay I want to
understand this is the only reason it's
not expanded to everybody is for
advertising
purposes um they were worried about
trans transparency um because I also
testified on this last year they were
worried that they wouldn't be able to
find out who won internally which with
this bill you're fully able to um take
all the measures that make sure that the
lottery is on the up and up um the other
thing that they're worried about is
promotional purposes some other states
have got around that by putting a very
small limit on it um but I think with
the wording of this bill I think we
cover that and with the blessing of the
head of the Lottery
Commission okay thank you y any other
questions seeing none thank you thank
you and I I don't see anyone else here
that wishes to speak on the bill so I'm
going to close the hearing on House Bill
485 and if there's no other business we
will adjourn for the
day okay thank
you
e e